Mit k Randy
So.
Heute ist schon früh, naja, früh ist es nicht, ich meine es ist 19.18.
Aber ich merke gerade, ich bin irgendwie ziemlich kaputt, aber ich, ich werde das trotzdem
schon aushalten jetzt irgendwie zweieinhalb Stunden ein bisschen zu schwätzen mit euch.
Mal gucken, ob die, Teams ist so eine Scheißsoftware, so eine Dreckssoftware, wie die immer da rum
stellt an dem Kram, ey, Lul, HD 4K.
Habt ihr euch mitbekommen, dass 720p auf YouTube mittlerweile schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr
HD ist, das heißt, wenn du 720p hoch lädst, dann ist es normal, die haben das mit deutschem
Internet noch nicht mitbekommen.
Wo es tatsächlich noch genug Leute gibt, die nicht mal 1080p gucken können.
Leider, aber es wird besser, aber es wird viel zu langsam besser.
Moin, ZD, wer ist denn sonst noch da, Sirius ist am Start, Mindcodes, Nütt, Topix, der
Max ist auch wieder am Start, BHLysium, SlickLP, Runman, ach Leute, ja, ich bin echt ein bisschen
im Arsch heute.
Wisst ihr was heute Morgen passiert ist, direkt, direkt, mal kurz zwitt, zeige ich euch, direkt
heute Morgen, China-Chinesen-Steckdosen-Leiste ist abgefackelt.
Ich meine, ich kann froh sein, dass es nicht Monarch S gemacht hat, so, also folgendes,
was ich machen wollte, also bei, bei was es abgefackelt ist, ich kann euch, ich kann euch
das ja mal kurz erzählen, also, ich bin im Keller, also die Steckdosen-Leiste liegt
im Keller, lag im Keller, der Keller hat eine relativ hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit, weil ich meine,
es ist ein Keller, ich weiß nicht, ob das China-Chinesen-Zeug vielleicht nicht damit
klargekommen ist, so, nee, zu viel Leistung gezogen kann eigentlich nicht sein, so, zumindest,
was ich gemacht habe ist, ich wollte noch ein zweites Point im Keller stellen, weil ihr
wisst ja, ich habe seit einer Weile hier im Haus ein Ruckus, beste Aussprache auf Deutsch,
ein Ruckus, Ruckus R710 und ich habe mir auf Ebay noch ein Ruckus R510 gekauft für den
Keller, weil, egal wo ich den hinhänge, entweder spackt die IP-Steckdose bei mir im Bad obenrum
oder dieser Ventil öffnen Schließer unten aus dem Keller hat laufend Verbindungsverluste,
egal wo ich es hinstelle, gibt keine optimale Position, wobei doch gäbe es, aber dort habe
ich kein Kabel um es anzuschließen, also egal wo ich den Axis-Point hingehauen habe, es
war immer irgendwas, so, ist aber auch, ich habe nachgemessen auch mit dem, ich habe hier
noch ein paar Android Tablets mit so einem WLAN Scanner und dann, also der Empfang da
ist wirklich mies an der Stelle, wenn das Signal aus dem Erdgeschoss kommt, so, zumindest,
folgendes, ich habe mir noch ein zweites Axis-Point bestellt, überhaupt kein Ding, es ist relativ
einfach sogar einzurichten, weil du keinen Controller oder sowas brauchst mit den Dingern,
sondern es funktioniert einfach, so, dann bin ich im Keller, im Keller liegt bei mir
relativ viel Zeug um an Technik, einiges was man gar nicht mehr braucht, also, zum Beispiel
liegt da ein Raspberry Pi rum, dann geht eine Menge Kabels, einmal für diesen Ventil öffnen
Schließer, den Kabel vorne an die Heizung, alles noch neben der Axis-Point und sowas
in der Richtung, so, und da lag halt so eine Kogic Steckdosenleiste, hatten wir ja schon
öfters, so, Spenni, danke schön für den Zap, so zumindest, die hatte ich da unten
hingelegt, weil es praktisch war, dass man halt die Geräte von oben und unten schalten
konnte, ich meine, das hat 4 Stecker plus USB, also, das war mal, das war mal diese Steckdosenleiste
irgendwann, ja, irgendwann sah die mal so aus, 4x USB, 4x normaler Schmuckostecker und
ich habe dann gedacht, was wird der neue Axis-Point, stell es da einfach neben den ganzen Technik-Krempel,
Stecker rausgezogen hier, hier, nee, ich glaube, der hier war es, Stecker rausgezogen und Netzteil
reingesteckt vom Axis-Point, ich gehe aus dem Keller raus, weil ich habe mein Handy
vergessen, ich gehe hoch an den Desktop-Rechner und gehe in meinem Home Assistant auf Steckdose,
auf hier einschalten und auf einmal macht es BÄM und ganze Keller ist Licht und alles
aus, da ist mal Sicherung rausgeflogen und da habe ich gedacht, oh, das ist aber schlecht,
das ist schlecht, bin ich runter in den Keller, habe festgestellt, ah, das riecht schon so
ein bisschen verbrannt und da hatte ich erstmal Panik, weil, ihr müsst wissen, an dieser
Steckdose, ja, Kurzschluss, an dieser Steckdosenleiste hängen im Endeffekt mehrere Sachen, da hängt
ein 12 Volt-Netzteil dran, was die Dashboards im Flur mit Strom versorgt, ich habe 2 Tablets
im Erdgeschoss und im ersten Stock hängen so als Automatisierungs-Dashboards, einmal
ein 12 Volt-Netzteil, das war da drin, ein Raspberry Pi hier am USB dran, an dem Raspberry
Pi ist die Tür-Gegensprechanlage dran, also im Zweifelsfall hätte es mir alle Tablets
gegrillt im Flur plus die Tür-Gegensprechanlage zerfetzt, wenn ich Pech gehabt hätte, ja,
so, und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was es gewesen ist, Tribull und danke für den Zap,
ich weiß nicht genau, was es gewesen ist, also entweder war es das Netzteil vom Access
Point, was aber äußerst merkwürdig wäre, weil ich hatte das Netzteil, gescheite, ja
dann such mal eine gescheite Leiste raus, die du remote schalten kannst, also ich hatte
das Netzteil für den Access Point 5 Minuten vorher oben bei mir hier noch dran mit dem
Access Point, kein Problem, ging, also ich vermute es ist die Steckdosenleiste und also
meine aktuelle Vermutung ist, dass vielleicht die Luftfeuchtigkeit im Keller zu hoch war
und das Ding irgendwie innen verklebt ist oder so, ich habe keine Ahnung, wobei das auch
wenig Sinn ergibt, weil in diesem Stecker steckte die ganze Zeit was drinnen, da konnte
eigentlich gar nichts rein, also vielleicht war es auch wirklich das Netzteil, die Sache
ist jetzt bloß die, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das gescheit testen soll, mal Frage an
die Elektrikors unter uns, also gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass man sowas
anschließt ohne, dass direkt die Sicherung im ganzen Haus raus fliegt, also gibt es irgendwelche
Sicherungen oder FI Schalter oder so in Steckdosenform, sodass dann quasi nur der raus fliegt und
nicht das komplette Etage ohne Strom ist, gibt es sowas, gibt es irgendwie Steckdosen mit
FI Schalter oder so und dann ist die nächste Frage, bringt das überhaupt was oder fliegt
dann beides raus, die Steckdose plus der vom Haus, ich weiß nicht, ob wir 5 Headige Elektrikors
da haben, was muss ich denn da suchen, du schein, Striker du kannst nicht, ja ich habe dann,
ich weiß, dass es das gibt, ich habe danach auch schon gesucht, die Kombination findet
man was, ich weiß aber nicht, ob das funktioniert, also fliegt dann nur, also geht dann nur die
Steckdose aus oder geht trotzdem nach wie vor das ganze Etage dann aus, wenn die Selektivität
gewährleistet ist, wie kann ich denn feststellen, ob die Selektivität gewährleistet ist, ok
also pass mal auf, also gehen wir auf Amazon, nach was muss ich denn da suchen, FI Steckdose,
weiß ich ob das so sinnvoll ist, ja sowas habe ich hier gefunden, ich habe keine Ahnung
ob das was taugt, ja, so jetzt mal angenommen, FI bringt beim Kurzschluss nichts, na auch
geil, was brauche ich denn, Style Personenschutzadapter, aha, ich wusste bis heute nicht, dass man
eine Personenschutzadapter, dass sowas gibt, ja aber ich brauche sowas ja in Steckdosenform,
aber ich meine sowas wird tatsächlich ganz praktisch, ich habe keine Ahnung ob das funktioniert,
na oh, oh was ist das, den hat es noch ein bisschen heftiger erwischt als mich, alter,
ein richtiger Monarch S, the fuck was hat der denn getrieben, hat er da einen Flammenwerfer
dran gehalten oder was, alter, ok Chat ich erkläre euch nochmal, was also falls jetzt
paar Leute neu dazu kommen, also heute morgen hat wahrscheinlich eine China Steckdosenleiste
bei mir in Keller den Geist aufgegeben und ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher ob es die Steckdosenleiste
ist oder das Netzteil was ich in die Steckdosenleiste gesteckt habe, also besser gesagt ist die
Sicherung im Keller rausgeflogen und naja da habe ich die Leiste abgemacht, die Sicherung
wieder rein und dann ging es wieder, so und ich würde jetzt gerne ausprobieren, ist es
die Leiste oder ist es das Netzteil, so und ich möchte das jetzt ungern, was ist denn
das, ich mache das mal auf was der Chat da postet, aha, ok den Hersteller kenne ich,
der ist nicht schlecht was sowas angeht, das habe ich schon öfters gehört, also zumindest,
so zumindest will ich jetzt mal die Steckdosenleiste wieder anstecken und ich will halt nicht das
meine komplette Etage gleich wieder ohne Strom ist, also aber Chat bringt, also mal angenommen
ich habe das jetzt ja hier auf was ihr gerade gepostet habt ja, wenn man sowas hier hat,
also Steckerleiste mit Sicherung, wie ist das denn dann, fliegt dann nur diese Sicherung
raus oder fliegt dann auch dahinter die vom Haus raus, das sieht stark nach Netzteil aus,
also das Netzteil, ja aber was ich nicht verstehe ist, was ich nicht verstehe ist, ok, weiss
nicht, ok, also wie ist das, fliegt dann nur die Sicherung von der Leiste raus oder auch
weiterhin die von der ganzen Etage, also wie ist das, nur die hier, ja weil dann könnte
ich das tatsächlich mal ausprobieren, also das was ist denn das für eine Sicherung,
das ist glaube ich eine richtig fette oder, also ich glaube nicht, dass wenn das irgendwie
eine 16 Ampere ist, dass die bedeutend kleiner ist, ich habe da zwar keine Ahnung von, aber
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so ein riesen Unterschied ist oder, ja mach mal
größer, Kirk Wade Alter, geiles Bild 2022, erkennt ihr es, also ich sehe alles ganz klar,
was ist denn geflogen, Sicherung oder FI, tja also ich kann dir nur das beschreiben
was ich gemacht habe und zwar ich habe so einen Sicherungskasten im Keller und da habe
ich ganz viele Schalter nummeriert und neben dran hängt ein Platt, da steht drauf welche
Nummer für welchen Raum ist und es ist die Nummer 20 für den Keller rausgeflogen oder
hat sich ausgeschaltet und dann habe ich den Hebel wieder hoch gemacht bei der Nummer 20
und dann geht es, also ich würde sagen, ja, nein keine Prüftaste, es war keine Prüftaste
dran, ich musste einfach nur den Hebel wieder hoch machen, hast du schon mit dem, das ist
eine gute Idee, da bin ich ja noch gar nicht drauf gekommen, ja das mache ich, das mache
ich, Sack Leute, Sack, wo habe ich das Netzteil, ach ne das Netzteil habe ich noch im Keller,
ne ich gehe jetzt nicht in den Keller, ich gehe jetzt nicht in den Keller das Ding holen,
das liegt noch im Keller, wobei Leute, soll ich in den Keller oder soll ich nicht in den
Keller, also ich würde in den Keller flitzen, das dauert 2 Minuten und dann mal den Multimeter
mal an das Netzteil halten und gucken ob es durch, ob es piepst, Bild vom Netzteil, ne
Bild vom Netzteil habe ich nicht, ok ich flitze, ich flitze, chat, gibt es Pepo Run, Pepo Run,
gibt es Pepo Run Emote, ich brauche ein Pepo Run Emote, Sack, jawoll, oh das ist gut, das
brauche ich, Pepo Run, Pepo Run, exellent, ich bin gleich wieder da, ok, ich flitze,
ich flitze, ich flitze, ich flitze, ich flitze…
Das war's für heute.
Okay.
Ich bin, ich bin wieder da.
Also wenn ich mir das Netzteil so angucke, ich mach euch mal ein Foto.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt keine Kamera.
Das Netzteil hat ein paar Abfackelspuren nebendran.
Wartet mal.
Säck, ich mach euch, ich mach euch ein Bild.
Wir machen jetzt hier.
Chatdiagnostiziert Problem.
So.
Wo lad ich euch das Bild jetzt hoch?
Ja Kellerstellz.
Also Moment.
Image.
Ich bin da drauf nicht vorbereitet jetzt.
Auf Pornhub?
Ja klar.
Super.
Beste Idee Leute.
Erst mal, erst mal auf Pornhub das Bild von meinem Stacker hochladen.
Und dann zufällig auf Pornhub gehen im Stream und gebannt werden.
Ganz bestimmt.
Ja.
Pfeil fährt.
Big Brain.
Entfernen die Metadaten, das machen die automatisch.
Also.
Steht die Leiste noch unter Strom?
Nein, die ist längst rausgezogen.
Ups.
Mann, jetzt hat sich das Tastaturlayout umgestellt.
Kacke.
Hier.
Also so sieht das Netzteil von der Seite aus.
Also durchgeschmolzen ist da nix.
Aber es hat halt so ein paar verkohlte Flecken dran.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Ja was ist denn nur mit Karsten los?
Ok, also meinst du das Netzteil ist RIP?
Ok, ich halte jetzt mal.
Ich halte jetzt mal mein Multimeter.
Sind am Netzteil Schrauben?
Nö.
Soll ich mal?
Ok, ich hole jetzt mal mein Multimeter.
Was soll ich denn machen?
Einfach hier unten mal gucken zwischen den beiden, ob es irgendwie Kurzschluss hat oder
so.
Pfeif hättiger Elektrikers Chat.
Was soll ich machen?
Gucken ob das einen Kurzschluss dazwischen hat?
Mach ich jetzt.
Achtung.
Ausprobieren.
So.
Ne, hat's nicht.
Also hat schon mal keinen Kurzschluss unten dran.
Keinen Kurzschluss Leute.
Keinen Kurzschluss.
Also nicht wenn ich da unten direkt rangehe.
Aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach komplett durch und deswegen gibt es keinen Kurzschluss
mehr.
Am Steck Pin Plus und Minus.
Ok, Pfeif hättiger Chat ist Pfeif hätt.
Nö.
Am Steck Pin Plus und Minus ist auch nix.
Hast du schon das?
Was von wem?
Ich weiß gar nicht wer das ist.
Clean zwar, war da nicht mal Fußballtrainer.
So vor 20 Jahren oder so.
Ne, da ist nix Kurzschluss technisch am Start.
So ich hab's jetzt ausprobiert Chat.
Nix, nix ist.
Ja.
Da kann alles mögliche sein.
Am Eingang sollte schon mal kein Kurzschluss sein.
Das Netzteil ist mir wurscht.
Ich weiß plötzlich ob ich mich noch mal trauen soll die Netz, die Steckdosenleiste anzuschließen
oder nicht.
Ich hätte überhaupt keine Probleme das beides wegzuschmeißen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber meint ihr das ist da drin ist so warm geworden das angefangen hat die.
Also mal angenommen.
Also mal angenommen die Steckdosenleiste wäre irgendwie, hätte irgendwie einen Kurzschluss
gehabt.
Dann hätte ja das Netzteil hier neben keine Branddinger oder?
Also da muss ja wirklich irgendwas drin geplatzt sein oder so.
Mach mal auf.
Ich glaube ich hab jetzt nix da um das groß aufzumachen.
Vielleicht hast du vor dem Einstecken einen Big Mac inhaliert und das sind die Fettflecken.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich gewesen sein.
Die Leiste hätte an den Löchern braune Spuren.
Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Also jetzt haben wir es wieder gesehen.
Chat, Twitch ist einfach so feifett.
Wir können quasi Twitch analysiert Remote was kaputt gegangen ist bei mir heute im Keller.
Wahrscheinlich hat er Chat sogar recht Massive.
Hi IQ wieder.
Ich sehs schon.
Das war folgendermaßen angesteckt.
Das Netzteil war hier so hochkant drinne.
So.
Also hier war es drinne und dann hier hat es drüber rausgeguckt das Netzteil.
Da war ein anderes Netzteil drin.
Deswegen ist da wahrscheinlich kein Dreck.
Das Netzteil war hier so drüber.
Also es ist im Prinzip auch genauer lang der Kante.
Was war in dem Netzteil angesteckt?
Der Access Point.
Der Access Point geht noch.
Wie gesagt die Flecken sind eigentlich nur hier oben.
Was er dafür sprechen würde, dass es das Netzteil war.
Guckt mal.
Das hier ist die Seite.
Überlegt mal.
Die Seite die hier verkohlt ist.
Das ist die Seite die hier so drangesteckt hat.
Die hier so drangelegen hat.
Dann war es wahrscheinlich echt das Netzteil.
Was meint ihr denn?
Angenommen das war das Netzteil.
Kann man denn dann die Steckdosenleiste...
Ich hab nix gerade da um das aufzumachen.
Ich müsste da jetzt mit so einem Minischraubendreher dran rumhebeln und hoffen das es aufgeht.
Geht das andere Netzteil noch?
Was für ein anderes?
Jaja.
Achso.
Das 12er.
Keine Ahnung.
Das 12-Volt-Netzteil keine Ahnung.
Hast du mal in deinem Netzteil gerochen?
Es hat gestunken in der Ecke als ich wieder in den Keller gekommen bin.
Na gut.
Also.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich trotzdem beides wegschmeißen.
Die Katze war das bestimmt nicht.
Aber ich.
Mein Desktop ja.
Mein Desktop ist massiv ordentlich.
Guck mal.
Aber ich bin durch den Chat mittlerweile so frei fertig geworden.
Dass ich auch das überblicke.
Also.
Jetzt mal zurück zu meiner eigentlichen Frage.
Mal angenommen ich würde mir jetzt hier sowas hier holen.
Nicht das Ding.
Sowas was der Chat eben empfohlen hat.
Und ich würde das da dran auch anschließen.
Also nein.
Das werde ich nicht mal anschließen.
Aber mal angenommen.
Ich würde da dran sowas anschließen.
Dann würde hier unten das Ding rausfliegen.
Oder wie?
Und nur das.
Und wahrscheinlich nicht das.
Achso.
Stimmt.
Doch.
Hat der Chat schon gesagt.
Also.
Wenn ich das dem Chat glaube und wir wissen ja der Chat erzählt aus Prinzip nie Mist.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Den Link den du da gebrauchst.
Ist ja am.
Ach nee, da steht es ja drinnen.
Ist Amazon?
Was soll ich denn damit?
Okay, ich mach das in der VM auf, man weiß ja nie, wo ich da rauskomme.
Kann ich, so hier, tinywool.com.
So, auf, so, tinywool, okay, Leute, highly secure alles, highly secure, Amazon, was
ist denn das?
Was soll ich denn damit?
Das ist, oder, hä, das ist eine Steckdose mit Schalter, und jetzt hat es eine extra
Sicherung, oder, oder was, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder,
oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder,
oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder, oder.
Das verstehe ich jetzt den Sinn nicht dazu.
Ich mach mal kurz Update, schade nix.
Aber zumindest Chat, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen schlauer.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche China Chinesen oder so.
Aber Fankrin, das was du vorhin geschickt hast und das, das sind doch jetzt zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe oder, das vorher war irgendwas, war irgendeine Leiste mit eigener
Sicherung und das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Man, das hat ne Kindersicherung, ja das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Gut, dann ist jetzt erstmal wurscht.
Ja, aber das mach ich jetzt nicht im Stream, das würde ich machen, wenn ihr zugucken könnt,
aber so ist doch langweilig.
Boah, da bin ich schlechter Ratgeber, was das angeht.
Ich kenne mich mit diesen ganzen eingebauten Lösungen nicht aus, weil das bei mir halt
nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Ich hab relativ viel Zigbee, Wlan und Wlan Geräte und Home Assistant, eben weil ich nicht
die Möglichkeit hab hier, sagen wir mal, extra Kabel oder sowas großartig zu legen.
Keine Ahnung, auf der anderen Seite, ich mein, das ist jetzt mit Vorsicht zu genießen,
weil ich das auch nur hörend sagen und vom Lesen her kenne.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das ja anscheinend nur das quasi Verkabelungssystem und das kann
man wohl mit vielen Sachen verwenden.
Also es gibt auch irgendeinen KNX Addon für Home Assistant, hab ich gesehen.
Also wahrscheinlich muss man da gar nicht irgendwie die offiziellen Dinger für nehmen
oder es gibt glaube ich sogar einen Raspberry Pi, den man da als Basisstation für nehmen
benutzen kann.
Aber das hab ich nur gelesen, nebenbei hab ich bei mir keine Erfahrung.
Welches Keyboard ich hab, ich hab aktuell ein Logitech, äh, gute Frage, ich guck mal
kurz unten.
Logitech, warum steht denn das da nicht drauf?
Leute, steht nicht drauf, ah hier, G512 Carbon, ok, alles klar, G512 Carbon, das da.
Also hier, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, welche Tasten ich habe.
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin damit überlegen, was ich für Tasten habe.
Weiß ich nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich glaub da sieht man auch nicht richtig.
Steht das auch da hinten drauf, was man für Tasten hat?
Mechanik, blablabla, nö, also keine Ahnung Leute was ich hab.
Na was ist net.
Nimm eine Taste ab, ok.
Ja und jetzt hab ich ne Taste in der Hand.
Ah die ist braun, unten drunter.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass man das so raus bekommen kann.
Also braun, braun wahrscheinlich dann.
Klipp, klipp, klipp, klimper, klimper.
Ja das Teil hab ich aktuell.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht ob ich nochmal kaufen würde, weil
die letzten zwei Tastaturen die ich hatte waren ziemlich, war ein ziemlicher Reihenfall
muss ich sagen.
Wobei bei der bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher abschließend, also ich hatte vorher
irgendeine Corsair, Corsair K95, so ein Ding hatte ich davor und
das war halt, also das war überteuert der Crap im Endeffekt, also ich bin überhaupt
nicht mit klar gekommen, dass Control nicht links außen von der Tastatur ist, sondern
diese komischen G-Tasten.
Ich bin öfters auf G6 gekommen anstatt Control, dann hatte ich das Problem, dass die Tasten
mehrere Anschläge hatten, also ich hatte mehrere Tasten, die hatten doppelte Anschläge
von Anfang an und das ganze Ding hatte einen äußerst metallischen Sound beim tippen.
Ich habe mir gesagt, ich
Ja und ich muss gerade mal dem bei was kommen so und jetzt habe ich halt die g512 und mit
der g512 hatte ich auch probleme das ich glaube tap ging nicht mehr nach einer weile und control
ist mir abgebrochen auf der g512 auf der letzten g512 und ich fand die g512 aber in sich ganz ok
deswegen habe ich mir noch mal etwas neuere g512 geholt aber wahrscheinlich würde ich das nie
noch mal machen g815 die logitech benahmung
ist aber auch nicht sonderlich logisch oder ist die flach das nix für mich mag ich nicht
ich mag keine flachen tastaturen ich kann mir da nicht helfen aber ich mag mag sie nicht
was gucken ob ich nix übersehen habe
alles klar gut also machen wir die ganzen temple mal zu dann gehen wir auf amazon also das hier
war schon mal ganz guter tipp was haben wir hier ausgerechnet oh wir müssen updaten also folgendes
ich brauche ich brauche ein paar sachen ich bookmarks mir mal falls ich es mal wieder brauche
ich muss mal ganz kurz ein paar tabs schließen ist mir bisschen viel youtube eine chance hast du was
gutes zu erzählen fünf anzeichen dass du gehackt wurdest seit seid ihr seid ihr schon drin bin
drin ja alles aber der typ der hat es echt übertrieben oder gut also was habe ich hier
noch was habe ich hier noch immer im wahren kopf alter was hat sich denn hier man ks was
hat es denn hier das letzte mal alles getan das brauche ich noch das habe ich schon das habe ich
schon habe ich auch schon kaufe ich mir nicht habe ich schon habe ich schon habe ich schon brauche
ich noch gut dass man den einkauf vorletztem mal aufgeräumt haben also ich brauche ich brauche
paar kleinigkeiten und ich hatte halt ehrlich gesagt keine energie mehr irgendwie großartige
bastel action im stream zu machen obwohl ich eigentlich gestern schon gesagt habe wir machen
bastel video aber ich habe es gestern auch nicht auf die reihe gekriegt gibt ein nettes video über
kim dot com von simplicissimus wenn das so video von simplicissimus ist dann ist das wieder
wahrscheinlich total mega dramatisch gemacht alles so übertramatisch ist das alles immer betont
der wasserkocher ist top da ist wenn er top ist hast du ihn auch zeigt mal vielleicht später
das da
da muss ich leute ich muss immer egal ich kann ich kann mir nicht helfen ich muss immer an
folgendes denken load load hast du vor mit facecam zu streamen
die typen hatten absolut kein plan für was sie hier eigentlich was einsprechen die hatten so
kein plan
die wussten garantiert nicht also ich bin mir gut keine ahnung aber das war wahrscheinlich
so das ist das stelle ich mir ähnlich vor wie leute die mir irgendwelche e-mail schreiben und
wollen dass ich was im video erzählen nur dass die eben ein management haben die das dann für die
ausmachen und das management sagt ihnen dann hier guck mal wir haben eine werbeanfrage sag einfach
mal kurz 15 sekunden i love mega upload ins video und dafür gibt 50k oder so und dann machen die
das halt das gehen auch am arsch vorbei was das ist wusste er würdest du im nachhine noch mal
werbung für g2a machen soll ich ehrlich sagen also ok meinst du jetzt würde ich heute noch mal
werbung für g2a machen oder würde ich wenn ich das wüsste was ich heute weiß damals noch mal
werbung machen für g2a das sind nämlich das sind das sind die sind die antworten nämlich ganz
unterschiedlich aus also das erste ist wüsste ich das was ich heute wüsste würde ich damals
trotzdem werbung machen für g2a und würde ich heute noch mal werbung machen für g2a wahrscheinlich
nicht die werbung für rate shadow legends ja ich habe massig anfragen davon letztens habe ich
habe letztens die 5 hettigste mail bekommen von rate shadow legends moment das muss ich euch
vorlesen hat man google hat mein ein map zugriff abgeschaltet ich muss es jetzt über den browser
machen oder mein sandal ordentlich einrichten moment die anfrage war so war so dermaßen
bescheuern wo ist es denn moment das muss ich jetzt suchen rate ok ok passt mal auf pass auf ich
gucke mal ich gucke mal ob ich euch die email kopieren kann warte mal ob ich will ich will keine
mails und sachen liegen ja ja ich kann es euch ich kann euch das kopieren sekunde ich ich zeig
euch ich zeig euch der anfang ist ist schon geil der anfang dieser mail ist einfach schon zu zu
geil ok ich zeige euch jetzt einfach also es sind keine mails und so trennen hier kommt mal das
intro ist schon zu geil haben deine followers auch die schnauze voll von monotonen und gespielten
ray schaumers erst mal sich selbst schlecht gemacht und dann sag ich übrigens willst du
nicht doch werbe machen für rate shadow legends alle wir wissen wie nervig es manchmal sein kann
wollen die situation dringend ändern ich bin oder steht doch dann egal ich bin jana von halbweg
wenn du uns noch nicht kennst wir sind eine blabla gerade suchen wir talente für rate mit leidenschaft
und kreativität auf der youtube präsent ja ok die sagen wir quasi erst mal im intro haben habt ihr
auch keinen bock auf gespielte und dann sagt ihr wollt es nicht eine runde spielen rate ist
besonders für seine aktive community bekannt ist das so muss ich nicht es hat großartige
grafik und ein element von rpg nostalgie das weiterhin neue spieler anzieht das entwicklerteam
veröffentlicht regel mich ablöten saisonale events noch angenehmer zugeschalten sorgt das
spielt immer noch als schlusssekretärin die uns wichtig sind 45 45 sekunden ein bildung am
anfang links in der description naja gut noch ist das ja komplett standard das würde ich
theoretisch sogar machen aber ich wette mit euch ich wette mit euch wenn ich wenn ich ein
video mache was würdest du dafür bekommen steht nichts drin steht nichts drin aber wenn man mal
von sagen wenn man bei wenn man mal von den preisen ausgeht die es normalerweise gibt für
halbwegs gescheite produkte und rate shadow legends ist halt ziemlicher mist dafür muss
es noch ein bisschen ein bisschen teurer sein und 45 sekunden sind auch nicht ohne also ich
würde mal sagen so 2500 euro oder so denke kann man dafür durchaus verlangen
ne mache ich nicht mache ich nicht aber ich fand es ich fand das intro allzu
geil haben deine follower auch die schnauze voll von monoton gespielt rate shadow legend
ha ha ha ne würde ich nicht würde ich nicht also also frage mal würdest du für das nächste
bettel viel wieder eine kooperation eingehen also im sinne von macht drei videos nach release also
normalerweise mache ich ja so so so bulk aufträge so für mehrere videos gar nicht weil ich weiß
dass ich mit content eh schon kaum rankommen aber in dem fall habe ich mir gedacht weil ich mich so
krass gefreut habe auf battlefield 2042 dachte ich mir easy drei videos machst du wahrscheinlich
mehr oder weniger in drei tagen so nach dem release und dann kam halt das game raus und war so abfuck
nein würde ich nicht und ich glaube auch nicht dass die mich noch mal einladen
ne ich habe ich habe drei relativ normale videos gemacht also ich habe ja also ich kann euch zeigen
was die promo videos waren das steht ja entweder im video und oder in der beschreibung drinne also
promotion video war
promotion video war das da was sind deine lieblings games so blöds klingt das fällt
mir schwerer spontan darauf zu antworten außer wenn ihr nur boomer games hören wollt und ich
werde sehr viele games vergessen wenn ich wenn ich mir da nicht näher drüber gedanken macht also
wenn man mal die games nehmen die ich am meisten gespielt habe dann ist es ok es ist definitiv
nicht rate shadow legends dann ist es eindeutig dark edge of camelot bei mmo's und irgendwie
sowas wie half life 1 was shooter angeht aber da müssen wir ein bisschen gedanken machen diablo 2
auf jeden fall auch aber ich müsste ein bisschen gedanken machen das kommt wirklich nur boomer
games bf3 ist auch ja würde ich schon sagen also das da war promo das hier war promo promo video
unterstützt durch die kuckt es euch an bärm das war promo video wobei ich sagen muss da hat
ich noch relativ bock drauf weil ich hier ein bisschen progas kram machen kann jetzt mal ehrlich
leute sowas hat glaube ich außer mir niemand gezeigt auf youtube weil die alle nicht den
high IQ chat an seiner seite haben für um den IQ soweit zu boosten dass man sowas machen kann ja
sowas hat glaube ich niemand gezeigt außer mir auf youtube so das ist block lie das haben die
als logik editor in battlefield portal leider viel zu beschränkt so das nächste das nächste
video war das hier perfekter start in battlefield 2042 da also bei dem video hatte ich noch richtig
bock drauf auf das portal video ja hier also ich hatte richtig bock drauf hier habe ich schon
gedacht fack alter was soll ich denn erzählen man das spiel sagt gut und dann musste ich noch eins
machen das hier für hazard zone und ich habe ein paar tage vorher mein fazit video hochgeladen
wo ich das spiel wurde spiel hat nicht gut weggekommen ist und hier ist halt dass das
das guck mal das ist das einzige video wo ich noch nicht mal ein thumbnail für gemacht habe
ist wie ist der der hän grün oder so der vorhin diese diese steckdosen leiste gepostet hat bist
du noch da was war denn mit dieser anderen steckdosen leiste die du da gepostet hast bei
amazon wolltest du die posten oder ist das gar nicht die richtige weil da stand jetzt
weder was von sicherungen noch von sonst was dabei das war einfach eine steckdosen leiste
mit mit schalter und ich fände es nicht schlecht wenn es sowas gebe wie das was du zuerst gepostet
hast aber halt mit etwas kleinerer sicherung so dass mir das nicht von der ganzen etage raus
fliegt ja überhaupt keine sicherung oder du hast du ich glaube du hast einfach nur
bei amazon steckdosen mit sicherung gesucht aber hier ist keine dabei oder das ist das
ist quasi nur china chinesen steckdosen leiste die zufälligerweise bei amazon auftaucht wenn
man steckdosen mit sicherung sucht was halt bisschen beschissen ist bei der amazon suche
ich habe auch schon öfters was gesucht nach mir das passt ja genau und habe ich nachgeguckt
und festgestellt ne das hat mit dem was ich gesucht habe gar nicht zu tun der an aus button
ist die sicherung ja pfeil fett super chat warum nicht das neue video pogo nice die amazon
suche ist richtig mies und wisst ihr kennt ihr das bei amazon ihr geht in die amazon suche
so ich hoffe ich kann jetzt sagen ihr sucht da zum beispiel nach steckdosen leiste wifi
so und was jetzt manchmal passiert ist es kommt es kommen gute suchergebnisse und die
verschwinden instant wieder und werden durch schlechte suchergebnisse ersetzt ok jetzt
ist es nicht passiert aber aber kennt ihr das bei amazon das ist total ja aber ich will
nicht dass sie in der verteidigung raus fliegt also mal angenommen ich will jetzt meine halb
abgefackelte steckdosen leiste einstecken und gucken ob die steckdosen leiste noch geht
aber ich will nicht dass die sicherung von meiner ganz von meiner gesamten etage raus
fliegt das ist ein riesen ding so 30 kilometer lange steckdosen leiste ist die rek rekbauweise
mäßig es ist recht mal und oder was was eigentlich ziemlich cool ist was kann ich
tatsächlich gebrauchen aber unabhängig davon so wo bin ich stehen geblieben genau die kack
amazon suche guckt mal wenn ihr amazon sucht manchmal ist es so es funktioniert nicht manchmal
ist es so dass auf das auf einmal gescheite suchergebnisse durch totalen krab ersetzt
werden ja war ja wahrscheinlich auch kurzschluss du brauchst eine kleine sicherung mit einer
schwächeren auslöse kategorie in der steckdosen leiste ja das wäre ja so in dem fall guckt
mal das hier ist eine 10 10 ampere ich kann es auf dem kopf nicht richtig erkennen und
ich denke mal dass die sicherung für meine für meine etage mehr ist das würde doch
dann funktionieren oder ihr seht wie planlos ich bin was solche elektronikers sachen angeht
ja das ist träge 10 ampere ok ich habe so keinen plan davon alle träge kommt später
das heißt im endeffekt geht dann trotzdem zuerst dann die sicherung im kasten unten
raus ja das ist schon echt kompliziert sich was zu kaufen sein stuhl brennt auch so lang
der klo nicht brennt ist alles gut ich sehe schon äußerst high IQ alles also wir fangen
jetzt mal was einzukaufen wird wird wird langsam wird es jetzt nicht zeit sonst kriegen wir
das mal wieder nicht gebacken wobei wir es 20 15 also letzte mal haben wir auch eine stunde
sind los gelabert bevor wir angefangen haben also übrigens eine sache noch eine sache noch
als noch als einwurf muss ich muss ich euch mal erzählen ihr wisst ja ich habe montags
arbeite ich nicht also ich habe ich ich arbeite nur vier tage woche und das halt auch nur
dienstag mittwoch donnerstag freitag so und ich habe heute mal aus spaß in meine emails
reingeguckt und da habe ich wieder was gesehen was mich instant geträgert hat was muss ich
das muss ich jetzt einfach mal los wenn kennt ihr leute die eigentlich was für euch machen
sollen und ihr wartet da schon irgendwie zwei monate drauf so und auf einmal bekommt ihr
eine nachricht von denen wo drinne steht max wie ist denn der stand fragezeichen dabei
wartet ihr schon seit zwei monaten darauf dass sich was tut wo man sich dann immer fragt
ist das jebait um von der eigenen sache abzulenken oder oder blicken die leute wirklich nicht
mal durch ich weiß nicht ich habe zwei anfragen heute bekommen max wie ist der stand und bei
den sachen habe ich eigentlich alles gemacht was ich machen konnte und ich will eigentlich
was das ist die reverse uno card ja das ist nicht recycle story das ist von heute wie
bei dir an der schule ok das finde ich das finde ich immer sehr weird champ erscheint
bei dir auch so ach jetzt wo du da bist du hast du hast doch diesen hecka hecka man keks
gemacht oder du bist doch hier der pfeil fertige animator was so was angeht für gifs
kannst du du bist in der lage eine high rest variante davon zu machen wenn ich dir einen
high rest keks schicke und weißt du auch wofür zeigs dir und zwar für das outro weil die
haben so nur nach 15 random outro aktuell dran gepappt weil wir nichts passenderes hatten
für das outro ich will in dem outro ein hecka man keks haben der aber ein bisschen höher
aufgelöst ist weil das outro passt nicht wirklich zu mir ist schön dass euch das video
gefallen hat youtube und dem youtube algorithmus gefällt es nicht so gut aber das war jetzt
zu erwarten erstmal ok aber jetzt fangen wir wirklich mal an hier einkaufstelle also
was brauche ich denn nochmal kurz dings gucken ok ja das brauche ich immer noch ja gut kannst
der vorteil von diesem video ist also von der art und weise von diesem video ist es
sowohl das gelaberte ein bisschen gestraft ich meine ich habe im stream 40 minuten zu
diesem thema gelaberter teil hatte irgendwie 39 draus gemacht das musste auch erst mal
hinkriegen und man kann sich trotzdem anhören ohne ohne dass man wirklich zugucken muss
alles klar also gucken wir mal also die sache mit der steckdosenleiste sind wir jetzt ja
los geworden ich fange mal oben an also wasserkocher brauche ich wasserkocher habe ich schon drin
wasserkocher wird wird ist ist raus so als nächstes ich habe mich verschrieben ich habe
mich definitiv ich habe mich definitiv verschrieben ich habe anus steckdosenleiste geschrieben
ich glaube ich wollte aber ich glaube ich wollte aber schreiben schauen schauen steckdosenleiste
das heißt ich wollte euch fragen wegen der steckdosenleiste das ist mein zweiter punkt
für meine to do liste heute und ich habe schauen aus irgendwelchen gründen so verkackt
auf dass der anus steckdosenleiste rausgekommen ist gachi bass ja ja ja wie was heißt ja
ja ja was soll das heißen selbst wenn es nicht so wäre 2022 alles kein problem mehr
sei mal ob es sei mal ruhig sonst wirst du direkt geshitstormt auf twitter ja das geht
schnell glaubst du das geht schnell wenn ich mir angucke wegen was manche wegen wegen nichts
manche leute geshitstormt werden auf auf twitter ist der wahnsinn statt die tastatur zu weit
rechts ja was von jr. hast du eigentlich nur maybe geschrieben ach moment ich hab dich
doch eben du bist auch im discord oder wurdest du gekickt glaube ich nicht oder du bist
im discord ich schickst du in discord bist nicht gebannt quatsch max es ist da ist da
chain lock gebannt im discord oder du bist du bist gebannt von discord kackel alter wie
hast du das geschafft ich hab gedacht du bist bei mir gebannt aber du bist einfach global
auf discord gebannt ja da kann ich dir auch nicht mehr helfen dann schenke ich dir im
discord neu was habe ich hier für leute bei mir im chat alter ich weiß gar nicht was
man machen muss um in discord gebannt zu werden wobei leute ich weiß ich war wieder als vergleich
wusste dass ich auf ebay klein anzeigen ich weiß recycle story ja aber wusste dass ich
auf ebay klein anzeigen gebannt bin und wisst ihr auch warum ich habe keine ahnung ich
wollte mir letztens in ebay klein anzeigen konto anlegen und und habe meine email adresse
eingegeben auf einmal stand drin ihr account ist irgendwie eingeschränkt ich hatte kein
konto bis jetzt nee und dann kam für alle die es nicht gesehen haben ich musste es einfach
noch mal zeigen weil das so frech ist weil das so frech ist die wäre was für dich ok
sack ah yes ich ich gucke gleich mal aber weil es so weil es einfach so frech ist muss
ich das gerade noch mal zeigen oh gott twitter fuck mich gehe mir nicht auf den sack weil
es so weil es so frech ist jetzt guckt euch das mal an so freche nachricht also ich habe
dann per support ich habe dann beim support gefragt warum ich habe kein account warum
ist mein account gebannt so und dann kam diese antwort vielen dank für ihre nachricht die
anmelde über nutzer konnte es nicht mehr möglich ich hatte noch nie ein benutzer konto und
jetzt kommt der hammer so frech alter so so frech diese entscheidung ist endgültig und
wir bitten sie daher abstand von unserem marktplatz zu nehmen weitere anfragen ihrerseits werden
wir gerne zur kenntnis nehmen jedoch nicht mehr beantworten what the fuck ich wollte
lediglich wissen warum mein account gebannt ist obwohl ich kein account besitze also das
ist wirklich das ist wirklich so recht diese antwort das habe ich selten gesehen ja gut
ich meine dann benutze ich den shit halt nicht soll mir recht sein ich meine ich könnte
mir einfach einen zweiten account anlegen also was heißt einen zweiten einen ersten
zweiten account anlegen mit der anderen email adresse aber das sehe ich nicht ein nach dieser
beschissenen antwort kriegen die kein geld mehr über ebay klein anzeigen bei mir man
muss dazu sagen dass ebay mit ebay klein anzeigen auch gar nichts mehr zu tun hat ebay
klein anzeigen ist eine komplett eigene firma also was was ist nice die hier
zwei versteckdosenleiste und die hat auch eine extra sicherung ah guck mal hier mit
feinsicherung ist feinsicherung der antwort führt dass sie nicht dass sie schneller ist
oder wie ihr wisst ich habe keinen plan davon gibt es auch bei amazon moment das kostet
jedes gleiche oder für eine schmelz sicherung aber wenn die schmilzt dann muss ich die doch
austauschen danach oder kann ich einfach den knopf drücken und ich habe keinen plan von
sowas ich muss mir das immer erklären als bald bin ich fünf ja ja gut das ist ein kaltgerät
das wäre jetzt nicht so wild das wäre nicht so wild ja genau so so so ein ding aber ich
will ja was wo ich den knopf drücken kann und dann ist wieder da ich sehe dass es wirklich
kompliziert egal wir fangen jetzt mal wir fangen jetzt wirklich an also ich brauche
nämlich ein paar sachen wo sind wir stehen geblieben was die anung steckdose die kommt
weg das haben wir haben wir schon besprochen wasser spore haben wir wasserkorre haben wir
ja was ich was ich mal nachgucken wollte ist nachdem es ja steckdosenleisten für wifi
weil zum flaschen nicht mehr gibt habe ich mir überlegt also ihr findet ihr findet keine
mehr die sich flaschen lässt das hier ist die letzte die sich flaschen ließ davon
habe ich mir auch noch ein vierer pack bestellt das ist im prinzip die gleiche steckdosenleiste
wie mir heute durchgebrannt ist also man könnte sagen wobei wie gesagt meinte die steckdosenleiste
wäre mir nicht durchgebrannt sondern das netzteil wäre kaputt gegangen ich weiß nicht
ob das noch der fall ist dass man die flaschen kann sollte das der fall sein dann ist es
tatsächlich immer noch zu empfehlen was
probiert ob sie sich aktuell noch flaschen lässt die ist richtig gut hält lange warm
ich bin hochgradig verwirrt
tiffany ist sehr sass ja vielleicht ist es ein china chinesen bot tasmota möglich 8
juni ok also dann wäre das tatsächlich ein eine empfehlung wenn ihr steckdosenleisten
sucht wenn man die noch flaschen kann was ich mal gucken wollte ist gibt es eigentlich
mittlerweile was mit sich wie was gescheites so noch so noch hat keine steckdosenleisten
oder die haben nur diese kleinen dinger so noch hat keine auf was ist das für eine
die kenne ich nicht warum hat die vier schalter warum hat die vier schalter nur drei steckdosen
also also wenn wenn jemand mal sus schreiben wollte in chat dann jetzt dafür also wo ist
der sinn weil warum hat es vier wenn es nur drei weiß ich nicht leuchtet nicht ein hat
es hinten sind es vielleicht gar keine anderen ausschalten sondern knöpfe die man frei
belegen kann ich weiß nicht ob man die tasmota flaschen
kann geht die geht die tasmota
die geht nicht mit tasmota die geht nicht mit tasmota die ist wahrscheinlich
kein esp 82 66
dann hat sich das wahrscheinlich erledigt ne also das das ist nix soll ich wollte mal
gucken gibt es diesen kram mit sich b vielleicht schon xenon sich b das hat ja hat ja super
bewertungen das ding schieder chinesen kram sich b mit problemen ich habe kombi und has
im einsatz das ist die kombination die habe ich auch also home assistant und einen kombi
zwei stick den kann ich übrigens empfehlen es wird ja öfter schon mal gefragt was sind
gute sich b sticks also es gibt den es gibt eigentlich zwei empfehlen zwei des ich b sticks
es gibt einmal den kombi ist also es gibt bestimmt noch mehr aber von denen ich weiß
dass sie taugen das ist der das ist der kombi stick und das andere ist mir fällt gerade
der name nicht ein war das da so noch stick hat das da so noch stick stick gewesen sein
ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher ob es das was war das also den habe ich den habe ich und
der taugt auch so und wo ist jetzt das problem damit leider gibt es wohl unterstützungsprobleme
schaltet man egal welchen switch so schalten sich alle steckdosen an oder aus einzuschalten
ist damit nicht möglich das ist ja unsinnig ja was denn jetzt am ersten april ist angeblich
alles gut damit und am vierten juni nicht schon wieder sus mich stört dass der an ausschalter
auch im aus modus leuchtet ja das ist leider aber viel im china chinesen kram so es der
april joke lull also das ist was was man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren könnte zumal
es auch zwei usb steigern finde ich eigentlich ganz cool was sagt denn shopping wenn man
danach sucht silver crest leute das sind alles china dinger diese namen das ist typ das sind
so typische china shop namen und es gibt auch genug china chinesen shops die bei amazon
d extra deutsch klingende shops machen damit die leute denken es wären deutsche produkte
aber man wenn man ein bisschen erfahrung bei china produkten hat erkennt man es ziemlich
schnell das ist die hässlichste steckdosen leiste die ich je gesehen habe hier selber
crest ist lidl das ist aber ein eins zu eins china chinesen produktname silver crest das
könnte eins zu eins china shop sein das typischer china shop name also das sieht mal scheiße
aus jetzt mal ehrlich also das sieht wirklich richtig mies aus als hätte jemand versucht
mit dem 3d drucker so flexi flexi rexi auszudrucken wie den weiß gar nicht wie dieses ding heißt
und daraus hätte eine steckdosen leiste gemacht
wisst ihr was ich meine 3d drucker flexi rex 3d print so ein teil meine ich hier oder was
doch so ein ding flexi flexi
wow massive performance flex flexi rexi und die haben lidl dies des hat nur drei die brauchen
die ernsthaft so viel platz für den controller da drinne was ist da drinne 10 backup zigp
controller oder was warum ist das so fett hier vorne ohne probleme eine vierte steckdose
hingepasst plus relays plus alles ich finde drei ist zu wenig so eine steckdosen leiste
das sie richtig sinnvoll ist braucht eigentlich vier stecker
das finde ich gar nicht schlecht das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool das finde ich nice
das mache ich mal rein wir haben im prinzip ohne scheiß wir haben alle keck emotes also
wir haben alle keck emotes der welt irgendwie na gut nicht alle aber aber sehr viele und
wir haben sehr viele pocky emotes wobei es schon mal weniger also es ist schon weniger
geworden ich habe versucht zu enden das geht nicht das ding sagt das ding ist mega schlecht
das ding ist mega schlecht das hatte ich mir schon mal angeguckt wisst ihr das ist so ein
typisches produkt von irgendeiner firma die keine ahnung haben was sie was sie was sie
eigentlich zwar taubtechnisch machen soll das problem dabei ist du kannst davon nur
zwei steckdosen leisten schalten über zigp und davon auch nur beide zusammen die restlichen
sind also die steckdosen sind immer an die habe ich mir nämlich auch schon angeguckt
diese leiste diese steckdosen sind immer an und diese steckdosen kannst du schalten
aber nur beide auf einmal also sie haben eine vierer steckdosen leiste gemacht und eigentlich
nur ein relay oder was auch immer da reingebaut die unsinnigste konstruktion aller zeiten
ja macht nichts also ich wie gesagt ich würde auch ich würde auch lydl das lydl ding ist
garantiert auch china chinesen kram das ist 100 pro china chinesen zeug wird mich echt
wunder wenn lydl den kram selbst macht oder besser gesagt lydl den kram in deutschland
irgendwo machen lässt das ist das ist china kram 100 100 pro ja es ist kein china kram
von aliexpress aber es ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich drei von fünf sternen weil er probleme mit
sick be hat nicht mit philipps you kompatibel ja ganz noobs die das verwenden mit dem offiziellen
hab kein quake ich glaube so ein ding werde ich mal ausprobieren ich habe zwar noch mehr
als genug steckdosen leisten auch wifi weil ich habe mir letztens noch ein fünfer pack
gekauft als als ich rausgefunden habe dass man diese hammer steckdosen leiste noch flaschen
kann das noch mal klug gehabt aber man kann steckdosen leisten kann man eigentlich nie
genug haben so next also was brauche ich denn noch an sinnvollen sachen ich brauche tatsächlich
ich brauche ein 48 volt netzteil für meinen router weil ich habe an meinem router mittlerweile
zwei access points und der hat da glaube ich schon so ein paar kleine problemchen mit poe
weil selber hat er bloß ein 48 volt 0,3 ampere netzteil und beide access points sollen mit
einem 48 volt 0,5 ampere netzteil betrieben werden weil sie das maximal brauchen nein
nein ich meine 48 volt ich meine wirklich 48 volt und das brauchen die natürlich nicht
aber ich sehe das bei der poe auslastung von meinem router das ist ein bisschen viel und
ja ich habe poe injectors aktuell dran weil ich das meinem router nicht zumuten will mit
dem unterdimensionierten netzteil ich habe im wohnzimmer oben aktuell einen 48 volt poe
injector dran nein ich meine wirklich 48 volt poe ist 48 volt also poe ist 24 oder 48 es
gibt glaube ich auch noch inoffizielles mit 12 aber im prinzip ist poe eigentlich immer
48 volt so und ich wollte einfach mal gucken ob es gescheite netzteile gibt zum beispiel
sowas wie 43 volt 3 ampere oder sowas ja sowas in der richtung genau top charger von den
von denen habe ich schon mal was gekauft das ist das sind irgendwelche poggers leute pop
charger ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht freund wrench achtung war ich doch da war ich
doch gar nicht so weit von weg charger charger top charger ja sowas wäre doch hier ganz
praktisch warum hatte schlechte bewertungen weil es kein china chinesen zeug ist nicht
für 13 s was hä hä was will der 47,7 ist doch vollkommen in ordnung was sind dann 13
s akkus jetzt will ich jetzt wissen 13 s akku ist es für drohnen oder sowas habe ich noch
nie gesehen ich habe keine ahnung was im notebook etwas aus dem notebook arad ich habe wirklich
keine ahnung aber ganz im ernst wenn du 48 volt akku hast dann lädt er auch mit 47,7
oder oder weiß was sagt der elektriker der wird wahrscheinlich sogar noch mit der ganzen
ecke weniger laden also es wird mich das wird mich doch sehr wundern aha ladespannung muss
höher sein ja dann ok du wolltest gerade sagen dann sollte sich nicht vielleicht so ein netzteil
holen sondern nadegerät für diese dinger also sowas ist sowas brauche ich sonst kackt
mir mein router irgendwann ab warum will am amazon immer diese komische versicherung
aufschwätzen jetzt geht jetzt überlegt mal ich hätte mir diese versicherung geholt für
meine steckdosenleiste das wäre wahrscheinlich ein aufwand von drei monaten gewesen bis die
mir die zurück erstattet hätten moin patrick so das hätten wir next es war nicht die leistung
ja weiß man ja noch nicht so das netzteil einmal ach leute stimmt ganz wichtig das brauche
ich jetzt tatsächlich und ich bin mir noch nicht sicher was ich mache ich habe t auf
mein mx 300 geschüttet auf mein mein poggers gutes mx 300 allerdings glücklicherweise nur
auf eine seite mit den polstern und ihr wisst ich habe noch ein mx 300 first generation das
ist wirklich antik schon fast das habe ich seit 2011 oder so das da mit den grauen so
eins habe ich noch und jetzt muss ich mal gucken gibt es gibt es die polster dafür noch weil
wenn es die polster gibt dann kaufe ich mir die polster ich kaufe mir kein neues mx 300
polster polster set das sieht nicht so gut aus wie das original das sieht das sieht schon
eher nach original aus ja guckt mal ist das ein unterschied ob first gen oder second gen
ne ja das sind die dasselbe mx 300 ist ja quasi in dt 770 mit mikro was bande was ist
was für ein fakt was ein band also mit innen drinnen brauche man nicht wobei ach moment
die petz sind da nicht drinnen oder was dann brauche ich die petz auch das ist garantiert
lasst mich mal kurz reingucken naja nee eigentlich nicht aber das 50 euro das sind viertel vom
50 euro alter moment das ist einfach nur das das ist ein bescheuertes set
ich weiß dass ich den nicht in silber brauche aber ich finde den silber netter ok wir gucken
aber bei biodynamics im shop ersatzteile service du kaufst dir einmal pro jahr ein neues set
auch für 50 euro ok oder für was auch immer schweizerfranken absorber scheibe produkt
wählen mx 300 ich habe die aller allererste generation die da ich finde die grauen netter
als die schwarzen ja da kann ich mir die opera amazon holen
kostenloser versand wunderbar
mir wurscht ob ich amazon supporte ich supporte gar keinen weil ich sie supporten will ich
kauf da wo es für mich am einfachsten ist aber in dem fall kaufe ich wahrscheinlich
wirklich bei bei biodynamics weil es auch kostenloser versand da kannst du nix kannst
du dich ja nicht beschweren dann so ich habe übrigens aus inoffiziellen quellen gehört
das ist aber auch schon drei vier monate monate her dass es bald ein neues mx 300 geben soll
ich weiß das um zwei ecken von einem der es weiß von einem der es bei biodynamics
weiß und von dem weiß ich also das im prinzip kann es auch genauso gut blödsinn sein das
wird es nie geben aber ich habe gehört es gibt bald ein neues
mx 300 so brauche ich weiter zur kasse na jetzt nicht ich check jetzt hier nicht mit
anschrift aus jetzt verliert er seinen job fack jetzt ist es raus jetzt jetzt ist es
raus abmahnung ist schon geschrieben ich sehe es ich sehe schon und chat ich habe noch mal
eine high q frage an euch dazu muss ich kurz etwas ausholen und zwar mein trucker ist absoluter
müll wie so ziemlich jeder trucker den es gibt das ist nämlich so ein multifunktionsgerät
mit scanner trucker faks wobei faks ist nicht mehr angeschlossen und kopierfunktion also
quasi scanner trucker kombi kopieren und faksen ist ja quasi nur bei werk da was zudem also
geht mit dem kannst du mit scan und kopieren ja quasi benutzen so und das ist kompletter
müll das ding ich meine ich habe start party tinte für meinen trucker aber trotzdem jedes
mal wenn ich das ding einschalte reinigt er sich fünf minuten und dann trug ich wieder
eineinhalb jahre nix ganz furchtbar ätzend korrekt danach wollte ich gucken könnt ihr
mir irgendeinen guten laser trucker empfehlen und zwar ich habe auch keine probleme bei
ebay irgendwas gebrauchtes zu kaufen oder bei amazon wenn das besser ist laser trucker
gleich krebs ist das wirklich so ich meine das bisschen mehr feinstaub macht es doch
jetzt auch noch mal aus ne farbe ist mir egal schwarz weiß reicht kiosera ok die haben ja
wahrscheinlich nur einen trucker oder das reicht wenn ich danach suche da finde ich
genau einen trucker und den brauche ich dann nach welchem soll ich denn genau suchen kiosera
äußerst griffige produktbezeichnung wieder m 5 5 2 6 cdw alles klar da weißt du sofort
bescheid nein leute ich weiß dass sie nicht nur ein richtig richtig das ist auch der
grund warum ich bin laser trucker haben will ich drucke quasi nie farbig und scannen bin
ich viel zu faul mittlerweile für ich fotografiere das einfach mit dem handy meinst du sie waren
eklig zu benutzen oder meinst du man bekommt krebs davon das ist schlecht das sind so das
hört sich an wie ein den wir früher auf der arbeit hatten so eine graue botnähe ist ein
anderer geht sogar also sagt mal leute wenn ihr sagt kioser apropos welcher welcher welcher
ist davon besonders besonders zu empfehlen also brother mfc so ein ich glaube das ist
das ding was wir früher auf der arbeit hatten das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor da gab
es auch ordentliche linux treiber unterstützung genau so ein ding so ein ding haben wir früher
auf der arbeit aber das ist vielleicht ein bisschen auf auf was heißt für mich oder
was letzt ok warte mal wartet mal was letzte preis wir gucken mal was letzte preis ist
gerade ok nix doch hier hier 550 euro heute kein bild sehr vertrauenserweckend ich weiß
ich wollte nur just for fun mal gucken was das da kostet vb was ist vb verhandlungsbasis
vb da wird ich gar nicht drauf antworten rosa also was was ist gescheiter also mir ist egal
ob es ein kioser oder ein brother ist das doch ok oder chat was sagt ihr ist das angemessen
199 euro scheint ja du hast keinen geschickt ja dann multifunktion ganz im ernst also ich
hätte da nix dagegen wenn es doch noch ein fax hätte kein fax alda nen scanner ja gut
wir sind in deutschland wer weiß wer weiß da brauchst du immer noch ein fax ne wenn
es wenn es noch ein scanner hätte ne ne ne leute ich brauch kein fax habe ich mich versprochen
aber man weiß in deutschland nie fax rosa hier sonst du du du du du du du du du du
naja ok du hast eingeschickt amazon nadeldrucker ja ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt nadeldrucker
alter na gut war nadeldrucker nicht das wurde sogar durchschläge mitmachen konntest oder
bring ich das jetzt durcheinander konnte man damit nicht sogar durchschläge machen
das ist mal richtiger oldschool shit hier das sieht aus wie aus dem letzten jahrtausend
und ist es wahrscheinlich auch
so
Lass es mal 5 Seiten im Jahr sein, wenn ich was drucke.
Und dann auch nur weil ich jetzt einen drucke hab, der da einfach funktioniert.
Ecosus, ja.
So isses.
Was haben wir hier?
Leiser Druck.
Also preislich finde ich den hier tatsächlich interessanter, zumal da auch noch ein Scanner
dabei wäre.
Den würde ich dann nämlich einfach noch bei mir irgendwo im Serverraum hinten abstellen.
Ist das Netzwerk?
Hat das Netzwerkport das Ding?
Hat das ein Netzwerkport?
Hat das Netzwerk?
Du bist echt voll über das Fax.
Gerade zum Kündigen mit Nachweis und so, aber es kann natürlich Scanner...
Da hast du nicht unrecht, allerdings, man kann natürlich den Kram, wollte ich grad sagen,
man kann natürlich auch einfach den Kram des Fax irgendwie über den Server verschicken.
Nee, HP will ich nicht.
HP hab ich aktuell, das ist Abfack.
Multifunktion Laserprinter.
Neue Drucker machen immer komische Dinger.
Die haben wahrscheinlich DRM im Toner und sowas.
Ja, deswegen, eigentlich braucht man das, hast schon recht, braucht man nicht.
Einfach so ein Scanner wäre tatsächlich ganz nice.
Hier beginnt, so, so, beginnt das hier.
Na, wenn das hier beginnt, dann gucken wir mal rein.
Hier beginnt.
So, Netzwerkport.
Bild, Netzwerkport.
Netzwerk.
Ah, kaufen Sie Passiv-USB oder Netzwerk, ok.
Verwenden Sie Netzwerker...
Oh, da weiß man schon, das ist top aktueller Bleeding Edge Drucker.
10 oder 100 Base T.
Ist der Drucker noch von vor oder nach 2000?
Ja, natürlich reicht das, das ist ja echt wurscht.
Das haben wir schon geguckt, ja, deckt sich mit meinen Erfahrungen.
10G, nein, 40G.
Heutzutage rendert man unkomprimiert, 8K, das muss ordentlich übertragen werden.
Natürlich reicht das, ein MBit reicht im Zweifelsfall auch, um den Kram zu übertragen.
Also, ich finde es eigentlich relativ sympathisch, so ein alles Ding zu kaufen auf Ebay.
SFP Plus Port mindestens, ach, da kommen wir zum nächsten, was ich brauche, ich brauche
noch zwei Direct Attach Kabel.
Direct Attach Kabel und nach Mück, warum sind denn die so billig?
Taugen die, achso, weil die irgendwie fünf Zentimeter lang sind oder so, ne, ne halber
Meter, nicht fünf Meter, ne halber Meter, also quasi 50 Zentimeter.
50 Zentimeter, lasst mal überlegen, reichen mir 50 Zentimeter?
Also ich muss, zeige euch das, ich muss, mittlerweile sieht es ja ein bisschen ordentlicher aus,
also ich muss von dort, na Moment, Mist, Max, zeig mal den Switch, auf, zeig den Switch,
so weiter ist er, also ich muss von dort, nur 10G, weil mein Switch nur 10G kann, mein Switch
hat zwölf SFP Plus Ports und vier 10G Krufer Ports, ja Chet, ich werde mir das, ich werde
mir das irgendwie mal angucken, den hättest du zum abgeben, ne ne passt schon, ich kaufe
mir irgendwo ein, ist nicht gemeint, aber ich krieg schon irgendwo ein, so und ich muss
von da, hier unten runter durch und dann hinten an Server, der Server steht hier unten, wobei
der hier nicht mehr da ist, sondern da jetzt der Microserver steht, das ist ein Raspberry
Player, das ist aber wie gesagt nicht, so sieht es da aktuell nicht aus, nicht mehr
aus, da reichen 50 Zentimeter nicht aus, das denke ich nämlich auch, dass da 5 Zentimeter
nicht ausreichen, so sieht es da aktuell drinne aus, also naja so aktuell ist es auch nicht
mehr, vor einem Jahr ist es her, aber so sieht es da jetzt drinne aus, das Unify Zeug ist
übrigens weg, das Video vom Serverraum kommt auch nicht mehr, was soll denn da nicht mehr
kommen, ich hab dazu doch schon, also vor einem Jahr hab ich da eins aufgeräumt, äh
eins aufgenommen, nachdem ich aufgeräumt hab, Moin Meister, ich hab dich gerade zu
fällig wieder entdeckt, war einfach eine Eingebung auf Klo beim Nachdenken, Klo ist
beste Sachen, also ich hab auch die besten Ideen immer auf dem Klo, das ist lustig, dass
du den Weg hierher gefunden hast, zumal ich komplett anders heiße, wurde dir das empfohlen
oder hast du dann bei mir auf YouTube geguckt und hast geguckt, dass ich online bin zufällig,
wolltest du nicht mal eins von der Firma machen, oh ja wollte ich, ähm wir haben, also Rechenzentrum
von der Firma filmen darf ich nicht, aber ich hab mit dem Felix zusammen ein Video mal
aufgenommen von Server Hardware, das hatten wir sogar damals gefragt, ob wir das machen
dürfen, aber das ist sehr viel Roh-Foodage, über das man doch mal drüber labern müsste,
vielleicht, vielleicht sollte ich noch mal fragen, vielleicht sollte ich noch mal fragen,
ob wir das dürfen, und dann je nachdem, was wir filmen dürfen, weil es ist ja nicht so,
als würden irgendwie, also Logos von der Bank da drauf pappen, dass man wüsste, wo
das ist und von wem das ist, das sind ganz normale Server, aber ein bisschen filmen wäre
schon cool, aber wahrscheinlich dürfen wir nicht, wahrscheinlich dürfen wir nicht, ich
denke nicht, dass wir dürfen, ich war ein paar Jahre lang relativ wenig aktiv, aber
in den letzten zwei drei Jahren wieder mehr, ja ich weiß, den würde ich wahrscheinlich,
aber ich bespreche das erstmal mit dem Felix, was der sagt, ähm weil ich brauche auf jeden
Fall einen, mit dem ich das zusammen aufnehme und der Felix hat einen guten Draht zu den
Leuten, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es geht, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall witzig, wenn
das funktionieren würde, letztens einen Switch mit 6x40, ja, da gibt es schon, mittlerweile
sind ja sogar 100G halbwegs erschwinglich, so, also wie gesagt, ich brauche zwei SFP
Kabel noch, also 50cm ist wahrscheinlich echt zu kurz, kann man hier aus, 0,2, 1m müsste
aber reichen, 13, die Dinger werden richtig schnell teuer, was ist denn das, warum kostet
denn, was ist das denn für eine Skalierung, 50cm mehr kosten hier das doppelte und 7m
kosten halt dann einfach mal nix oder was, hä, 1 und 2m kosten einfach mal exakt das
gleiche, na dann, äh, dann hole ich mir einfach mal zwei Stück davon, das ist was anderes
hier was kosten die, 13,99 der kam kostet anscheinend immer das gleiche, die sind wahrscheinlich,
lasst mich raten, viel zu teuer, weil, warum machen bitte schön, warum machen die eigene
Direkt Attach Kabel, das ist ja nicht so als preußes oder super Spezial Dinger, intellkompatibel,
also bis jetzt habe ich es noch nicht erlebt, dass Direkt Attach Kabel irgendwie, ok, Parsisco
bin ich mir da immer nicht sicher, aber, und manche Switcher haben Probleme mit speziellen
SFPs, aber Direkt Attach Kabel haben eigentlich bisher immer, also ich hatte noch nicht einen
Fall, dass die nicht funktioniert haben, ok, Tropic sagt anscheinend doch, also ich hatte
noch nix, bei mir haben die immer funktioniert, Unify ist mega scheiße, ja gut, das wundert
mich nicht, vieles bei Unify ist mega crap, deswegen habe ich Unify auch rausgeschmissen,
komm ich bestelle mir jetzt einfach zwei Stück davon, umgutes, ein Meter, ein Meter SFP plus,
das reicht, oder, ich mein, Leute, wenn für den gleichen Preis, kann ich einfach auch
zwei Meter nehmen, ich mein, im Zweifelsfall lasse ich halt so eine Rolle drin, komm ich
nehme zwei mal zwei Meter, warum sollte ich nur ein Meter nehmen, wenn ich zwei Meter
haben kann, im Zweifelsfall lasse ich hier einmal so ein Kringel liegen und gut ist,
das kostet drei Meter, ein Euro mehr, ne, dann wird es schon zu lang, haben wir hier
zwei Stück, Leute, hat irgendjemand die Matrix-Fortsetzung geguckt, also ich hab das ja bisher gemieden,
Matrix 1 ist mein, ich würde nicht sagen, mein absoluter Lieblingsfilm, aber einer meiner
absoluten Lieblingsfilme, die Fortsetzung fand ich schon nicht sonderlich gut damals,
aber den leider ja, ok, wahrscheinlich nicht so tolle, oder, Handservice, ich mein, Matrix
war halt super in sich abgeschlossen, also, allein schon deswegen, ich weiß nicht, ich
glaube, wenn es das mal bei Prime gibt, werde ich mir das geben, ok, zwei mal SFP plus Kabels
am Start, du hast den mit einer 4 von 10 bewertet und meine schlechte, ok, das heißt, ja, irgendwann,
vielleicht wenn es das mal Prime dabei gibt, ist mir nur gerade eingefallen, weil man das
hier gesehen hat, also, so, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, Crample, Next, was brauchen wir,
ja, stimmt, was ich gucken wollte ist, so als Backup, ihr wisst ja, ich hab's mittlerweile
bei mir im Mini, ich stell's mal im Mini-RZ, hab ich so, ich hab hier unten die Kiste,
den eigentlichen Server drin hängen, ja super, Max, wo ist es dann, ja, Kamerakünste sind
halt nicht der Wahnsinn, ihr wisst ja, ja, hier, da unten ist die Kiste, also, den hab
ich ja da nicht mehr, da steht jetzt ja dieser HP Micro Server drunter und die USB gibt's
auch nicht mehr, weil die USB das einzige war, was hier in meinem Rack kaputtgegangen ist
und dann war das ganze Rack aus, ja, alles fehlerfrei gelaufen seit 5 Jahren und dann
verreckt die USB, das musst du auch erstmal schaffen, das ist echt der Wahnsinn, das ist
ein echter Klassiker, ja, so, zumindest hier unten steht die Kiste, da steht aktuell der
Micro Server und ich hab hier neben, ich glaub, man sieht das, man sieht das in dem Video
auch, irgendwo, normalerweise steht hier eine externe USB Platte, irgendwo, die da, wo grad
der Stufenbohrer liegt, was ein Stufenbohrer ist, hat mir letztens der Chat erklärt, ich
habe fehlerhaft angenommen, es wäre ein Kegelbohrer und da hat der Chat gesagt, nein, Max, das
ist kein Kegelbohrer, das ist ein Stufenbohrer, deswegen weiß ich jetzt, dass es ein Stufenbohrer
ist, also falls ich mal irgendwann abgefragt werde, so Einstellungstest oder sowas, was
ist der Unterschied, Stufenbohrer, Kegelbohrer, dann weiß ich Bescheid, die USB, also das
ist eine Cyber Power, die ist mir verreckt und leider, was ich dabei festgestellt hab,
gute USB lassen den Strom durch, tja, hätte ich auch gedacht, das hätte ich auch gedacht,
aber wahrscheinlich ist ja nicht die USB verreckt, sondern die Batterie und es ist einfach komplett
ausgegangen und das, obwohl der Strom aus der Wand noch funktioniert, hat zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Müll, also USB ist auch weggeflogen, deswegen haben wir das letzte Mal geguckt, ob ich mir
nicht eine kleine USB wiederhole, jetzt hab ich ganz vergessen, was ich eigentlich machen
wollte, wo bin ich stehen geblieben, ich muss mal kurz in meine Einkaufsliste gucken, Sekunde,
ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, aber zumindest das haben wir jetzt, Backup externer HD, der
Chat weiß es wieder, der IQ ist zu hoch mittlerweile, das ist einfach komplett durch die Decke,
der Chat weiß eher, was ich machen wollte, als ich selbst, genau, und ich hab aktuell
hier eine externe Festplatte stehen und das ist eine 10TB Platte mit so einem komischen
Shacoon USB 3.0 Gehäuse, das Dumme ist, das ist relativ langsam, weil das ist ein oldschool
eines der ersten USB 3.0 Gehäuse gewesen, würde jetzt eigentlich sagen, für die Festplatte
reicht es, aber sogar dafür reicht es nicht so ganz, und das eigentliche Problem was ich
habe ist, dass hier oben, also die Festplatte steht aktuell hier hochkant, so, und ich hab's
letztens geschafft mit meinem 3D Drucker was auszudrucken, übrigens, das hab ich euch
auch gezeigt, das sind diese Leisten für das Regal, was ich ausgedruckt hab, da wo
der Access Point dran hängt, und ich hab's geschafft beim Abmachen mit dem Spachtel,
man muss ja 3D-Drucker immer mit so einem Spachtel abmachen, wenn man sich ordentlich
abkühlen lassen will, und da hab ich's doch geschafft, fast, fast, nicht ganz, mit dem
L-Bogen meine Festplatte runterzuschmeißen, und da dachte ich mir so, eigentlich ist die
Position da oben richtig hängen geblieben, und dieses Stecksystem unter langsamem USB-Anschluss
ist auch ziemlicher Müll, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, was ist denn die größte externe
Platte, gucken wir mal bei Geizhals, die es gibt, die halbwegs, aber auch preisleistungsmäßig
passt, oder Chet, was würdet ihr sagen, externe Platte im Gehäuse fertig aus, oder noch ein
neueres Wechselgehäuse und dann eigene Platte rein, dazu muss man sagen, dass die externen
Platten meistens sogar noch einen Ticken günstiger sind, als die Platten so zu kaufen, warum,
ich hab keine Ahnung, vielleicht machen sie da minderwertige Platten rein oder so, keine
Ahnung, da gucken wir mal Festplatten extern, ne, die alte Platte ist back-up technisch
nahezu dicht, da ist auch ein Terabyte oder so frei, ich hab halt einmal, als ich jetzt
das neue System am Start hab, ich hab halt einmal back-up gezogen, initial wieder von
allem und hab's dann halt auch gleich geback-upped auf die externe Platte, so und das war vielleicht
keine so schlaue Idee, vielleicht lösche ich auch nochmal die ganzen back-ups und back-upper
jetzt wirklich nicht so hirnlos, wie ich's gemacht habe, weil ich ein fauler Sack bin,
ich hab total hirnlos geback-upped, ich hab quasi so gemacht, hier guckt, wenn ich quasi
hergegangen hab, ach komm lass mal kurz back-upen, 500G, obwohl halt zu der Hälfte, das was
da drauf ist, ich 80% gar nicht brauche, machst du mal Dev-Wop-Stream mit C, E, C, D, Pipeline,
Docker-Stuff, haben wir schon öfters gemacht, guck mal, Arschi, zumindest, zumindest, ähm,
ist das auch noch gar nicht so lange her, ah, jetzt, exellent, beste, beste Theme hier überhaupt
für diese Seite, guck mal, wir hatten, äh, Pack W, S, äh, Service, ne, ähm, Max, kann
das sein, dass man da nicht richtig suchen kann?
Wo ist es denn?
KekW?
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet, wenn ich KekW, S, äh, Service eingebe, ah ne, hat er doch,
was, das ist schon 2, ne, das ist keine 2 Jahre her, ach ne, das hier war das, KekW,
S, Service zieht um, hier, hier haben wir so ein bisschen, hier haben wir so ein bisschen
was in dieser Richtung gemacht im Stream, ok, das ist jetzt keine, ähm, Geschichte irgendwie
mit, mit, mit Google Cloud und dort irgendwie über GitHub und sonst was, wir haben die Light-Variante
gemacht, die aber finde ich für die meisten, auch kleinere Projekte vollkommen ausreicht,
ja, also wir haben eine Mini-Web-Anwendung gebaut und dann, pfeifertiges Paint-Bild dazu
gemalt, ja, dann haben wir Loadbalancer davor gehängt, EU-Standort, NA-Standort, äh, DNS
bei, bei, bei Ausfall, die Anycast, Anycast-DNS, haben wir den Anycast-DNS wirklich davor gemacht,
kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, Anycast-DNS, das, das zurückliefert, was
am nächsten dran ist, kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, so, hier ist KekW,
S, Service, das rotatet bei jedem Seitenaufruf, random, einmal KekW und dann haben wir das
ganze über GitHub Actions deployed, irgendwie, irgendwo in diesem Stream, Ansible ist auch
am Start gewesen, ja und mit GitHub Actions und Ansible kommste doch schon relativ weit,
ich hab keine Ahnung wo wir die GitHub Actions gemacht haben, zumindest unsere, ich kann sie
dir eigentlich zeigen, KekW, KekW, S, Service, also unsere GitHub Actions ist halt äußerst
rudimentär gewesen, wir haben nichts anderes gemacht, wie die Anwendung zu bauen und dann
uns über das Hetzer-CLI die aktuellen Server zu holen, die getaggt waren mit KekW, S, Service
und dann haben wir eine Schleife drüber gemacht und haben die Anwendung dahin deployed und
den Service neu gestartet über System D, ne, das stimmt nicht, Chat, das ist, nein, nein,
nein, das stimmt nicht, also der Unterschied zwischen Multicast und Anycast ist eigentlich
was komplett anderes, obwohl es ähnlich klingt, das stimmt nicht, also Multicast ist das was
du verwendest wenn du beispielsweise, ja Broadcast ist, ja Broadcast geht, ist aber eigentlich
nochmal für was anderes da, Broadcast verwendest du für solche Sachen wie Abanfragen zum Beispiel,
Abanfragen ist das was dir lokal im Netz MAC Adressen zu IP Adressen auflöst, ne Schwachsinn,
IP Adressen zu MAC Adressen auflöst, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel das hier machst,
guck mal, Ping 122168 1.69, so wenn du das hier machst, was dann passiert ist, ich meine
das funktioniert jetzt nicht, weil ich die IP nicht habe, wenn du das machst passiert
folgendes, der schickt einen Broadcast raus, der schickt einen Broadcast raus mit einer
Abanfrage und fragt Leute wer hat denn die 122168 1.69 und dann antwortet das Gerät
mit seiner MAC Adresse, weil lokal im Netz zustellen, also auf Ethernet Ebene geht ja
nur per MAC Adresse, IP Adressen sind da vollkommen egal für, IP Adressen brauchst du im Endeffekt
um dein Lokal, also IP Adressen brauchst du zum routen über Netze hinweg, aber lokal
musst du dann im Endeffekt gucken, was ist denn jetzt die MAC Adresse für diese IP Adresse,
genau und dann sagst du who has und dann kommt als antwort, ja hierhin die Antwort schicken
und dann kommt als antwort was mit der MAC Adresse, so Sachen macht man über ein Broadcast,
wenn du beispielsweise wissen willst wer hat welche MAC, das muss an alle gehen aber Broadcast
ist äußerst ineffizient und Broadcast willst du beispielsweise nicht verwenden um Video
zu übertragen, zum Beispiel auch wenn es Fernseh Broadcast heißt aber das hat mit
Ethernet Broadcast nichts zu tun, Twitch Mason Dankeschön für den Zap, Multicast wiederum
ist das was du verwenden willst wenn du zum Beispiel Videos übertragen willst oder Streams
übertragen willst an mehrere Gruppen, bei Multicast ich glaube ich Leute lass mich jetzt
nicht lügen, ich glaube 2240008 oder so, was ist Multicast, naja hier 2240008 dann wahrscheinlich
oder so und da kannst du je nachdem in welche Gruppe du gehst bzw. halt in welches Subnetz
du gehst kannst du über Multicast zum Beispiel relativ gut Videos verteilen, da kannst du
nämlich sagen hey ich geh jetzt in eine Multicast Gruppe und dann schickst du einen Video Stream
und die Netzwerkgeräte handeln dann das verteilen an die Endgeräte, das heißt du musst nicht
an jeden Client deine, zum Endicast komm ich gleich, ich muss das jetzt ordentlich,
wer mal schon dabei ist ich muss das ordentlich erklären, wenn du beispielsweise nicht an
alle einzelnen Zuschauer deine Video Streams verschicken willst, sondern wenn du deinen
Video Stream nur einmal verschicken willst und die Leute können sich dazu quasi subscriben
rein in die Multicast Gruppe, dann funktioniert das so, per Multicast und jetzt kommt Anycast,
Anycast hört sich so an wie als hätte es was mit Broadcast oder Multicast zu tun, hat
es aber gar nicht, Anycast wird zum Beispiel dafür verwendet, dass du den nächsten DNS
Server ansprichst, das funktioniert vollendermaßen, der Google DNS 8.8.8.8, den gibt es 85 mal
auf der Welt, aber das Routing unterwegs ist so schlau und kann dieses Netz, wo der
Server drin steht so routen, wahrscheinlich im Endeffekt über irgendwelche Kosteneinträge,
zwischen Netzen, wie auch immer ist egal, zumindest wirst du so geroutet, dass du in
der Regel bei dem Server rauskommst, der bei dir in der Nähe ist, also das heißt, wenn
ich jetzt 8.8.8.8 pinge, dann ist das relativ schnell mit einem Ping von 18, wenn ich in
den USA bin und 8.8.8.8 pinge, ist es ähnlich schnell, was ja nicht gehen würde, wenn es
8.8.8.8.8 nur einmal auf der Welt gäbe, weil irgendwo wäre es langsam, ist es aber
nicht, weil Anycast, das ist in der Umsetzung gar nicht so komplex, weil anscheinend haben
wir es in diesem Stream hier gemacht, wo auch immer, also anscheinend haben wir es testweise
in diesem Stream gemacht, ich weiß aber echt nicht mehr, wie wir das gemacht haben, also
wir haben es halt so gebaut, wir haben einen Load Balancer in EU gehabt, einen Load Balancer
in NA gehabt und dann jeweils 3 App Server dahinter und dann haben wir so, dann haben
wir einen DNS Server hingestellt, ja ich weiß wieder, wie wir das gemacht haben, das war
tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig, wir haben von GitHub einen DNS Server genommen, der
eine Geodatenbank dabei hatte und der hat geguckt von der Absender IP, in welchem Land
ist der Absender dieses DNS Queries und hat dann anhand dessen, nee, wir haben gar kein
Anycast gemacht, ich hab nix gesagt, wir haben gar kein Anycast gemacht, wir haben ganz normales
DNS Load Balancing gemacht, aber anhand von Geo Anfragen auf unterschiedliche Services
weitergeleitet, ok, dann hab ich nix gesagt, wir haben kein Anycast gemacht, so, Twitch
Maze, danke für den Sub, ja das ist jetzt wo ich mir überlege, ist das auch ziemlich
komplex und das kannst du auch nur machen, wenn du das Routing-Protokoll technisch irgendwie
announcen kannst, was das heißt announcen kann, irgendwie das mitbestimmen kannst, wie
die Kosten für die Routen sind, das heißt, das kannst du daheim beziehungsweise einfach
mal so random bei irgendeinem Host da eh nicht machen, das musst du dann bei irgendeinem
extra Anbieter machen, der das supportet, das ist interessant, das hab ich auch noch
nie gemacht, das muss man sich tatsächlich mal angucken, ja ja Topix wusste schon wieder
alles, ja, schon fünf Minuten bevor die Frage gestellt wurde wahrscheinlich schon, hab
dein neues Video gesehen, mega unterhaltsam, da wollte ich mal fragen, ob du eine Router-Empfehlung
hast, Preisklasse circa 150 Euro, da muss ich jetzt meine obligatorische Frage stellen,
Adabums, Dings, Badums, danke für den 23 Monate Massive Prime Subscription hier, da muss ich
jetzt so mal die obligatorische Frage stellen, willst du wirklich einen Router haben oder
willst du ein Multifunktionsgerät haben, ich vermute du willst ein Multifunktionsgerät
haben, also ich vermute du willst so was haben wie die Fritzbox, bloß dass du dir denkst,
es gibt vielleicht was besseres wie die Fritzbox, was aber das macht, was die Fritzbox macht
nur besser, du willst ein Modem plus Router, ok, du willst ein Modem in einem Gerät oder
du willst ein Router plus Modem anschließen, weil wenn du irgendwas suchst, was auch nur
halbwegs einer Fritzbox ähnelt, dann würde ich einfach eine Fritzbox kaufen, weil die
Dinger sind für den Heimbereich echt nicht schlecht, die Fritzbox, die kann zwar keine
Routingprotokolle, brauchst du aber daheim eh nicht, die kann keine VLANs, brauchen
die meisten Leute daheim auch nicht, es wäre vielleicht cool, gerade VLAN Support wäre
echt praktisch, aber es geht, es geht, also Modem plus Router, ganz ehrlich, was spricht
gegen eine Fritzbox, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob du Fritzbox, das ist ja, stimmt, das ist
auch so was, ich glaube ausgehende Firewall regeln kannst du in der Fritzbox auch nicht
machen, ja, man muss halt sagen, eine Fritzbox ist eigentlich kein Router, eine Fritzbox
ist halt ein Multifunktionsgerät, aber wenn man auch nur ein paar Funktionen davon braucht,
dann ist die gar nicht schlecht, ja, zum Beispiel, ich meine es gibt durchaus ein paar Alternativgeräte,
aber die Kombination, die Kombination bei der Fritzbox ist halt eigentlich ganz nice,
du hast eine Deckbasis Station, viele Leute haben immer noch Decktelefone, du kannst da
mit VoIP und SIP machen, für beispielsweise mit dem Handy telefonieren intern, ja, du
kannst dann SIP klein installieren und mit dem Handy telefonieren über deine Festnetznummer
und solche Dinge, weil ganz im Ernst, Voice-Over-IP willst du einfach nicht selbst machen, das
ist also größter Abfuck, den es gibt, dann hast du alle Sachen, was du brauchst, von
Modem, bist ein ganz billiges Nass dabei, du kannst da eine externe Platte dran schließen
und sowas, wenn du eine Kabel Fritzbox hast, hast du sogar noch einen Quad-Tuner dabei,
wo du dann vom Raspberry Pi Fernseher aufnehmen kannst und sowas, also ganz im Ernst, wenn
du auch nur ein bisschen mehr an Multifunktion brauchst als einen popeligen Router, dann
ist die Fritzbox gut, wenn du als allerdings einen wirklich guten Router brauchst, was
auch Durchsatz angeht beim Routen, ich meine nicht beim Switchen, ich meine wirklich beim
Routen, von einem Netz ins andere oder wenn du advancedere Firewall-Regeln brauchst oder
wenn du gar Routing-Protokoll und VLAN-Support brauchst, dann ist eine Fritzbox nix, aber
ich glaube du brauchst einfach ein gutes Multifunktionsheimgerät und dafür ist die
Fritzbox echt nicht schlecht.
Aha erinnert mich an ein Interview kurz vor der Ausbildung, da hatten die mir ein DSL-Multifunktionsgerät
hingestellt, das habe ich auch so betitelt, hat mich die Stelle gekostet, hä warum, wollten
die das so sagen, das ist ein Router oder was, und du hast gesagt, das ist ein Multifunktionsgerät,
das war bestimmt die Personalabteilung, die von nix eine Ahnung hatte oder, ich meine
also mal ganz im Ernst, wenn da auch nur ein bisschen Ahnung von der Technik da sitzt,
man sollte es eigentlich zu schätzen wissen, dass du das korrekt benennst, weil es ist
kein Router im eigentlichen Sinne, also es ist ein ziemlich schlechter Router, wenn man
sich nur das Routing anguckt bei der Fritzbox, es ist ein ziemlich gutes Multifunktionsgerät.
Ja, deswegen, finde ich nicht verkehrt, äh wenn ich eine Fritzbox habe und dahinter
einen Router setze und diese per 100 m mit LAN verbunden sind, habe ich da ein Flaschnalz,
wenn der Rest vom LAN, nö, hast du nicht, hast du nicht, ins Internet raus ja, ins Internet
raus, falls es schneller geht, oder was heißt ins Internet raus, wenn du noch weitere Geräte
an der Fritzbox angeschlossen hättest, von denen du, ähm, über diesen Router drauf
zugreifen willst, ja, dann schon, also würdest du jetzt dein NAS an die Fritzbox hängen und
die restlichen 1GB Geräte an den Router, dann wäre das eine, ähm, ziemliche 3-Head-Idee,
aber das wirst du ja wahrscheinlich nicht machen, ne, da hast du keine Probleme, denn
in der Regel ist es so, dass auch der Router da nicht so viel, ähm, damit ausmacht, sondern
eher das Switch-Modul, was in diesem Router drinne ist, weil Routen im gleichen Netz geht
ja gar nicht, das sagt ja schon das Wort Routen, Routen kannst du nur von einem Netz
ins andere, ein Router, ein Router würde beispielsweise nicht funktionieren, stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt einen Router mit zwei Ports und ihr steckt an beide Ports Geräte dran mit dem
gleichen Netz, rein auf Routerebene könnte das nicht funktionieren, glücklicherweise
hat so gut wie jeder Router noch ein Switch mit drinne, und deswegen funktioniert das,
also der Routing-Part von deinem Router ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht der, der da irgendwie
viel macht, sondern die Ports sind wahrscheinlich standardmäßig in irgendeiner Bridge zusammengefasst,
und das heißt du kannst im gleichen Netz superschnell Sachen austauschen und das interessiert
überhaupt gar keinen, das funktioniert, das kannst du machen, ich hatte das übrigens
auch lange Zeit so, ich hatte an meinem Router Fritzbox dran mit nur 100 Mbit, die hab ich
immer noch, Mist jetzt, ich hab Mist erzählt, hab ich ja aktuell immer noch dran, die andere
hab ich ja noch gar nicht angeschlossen, ja und das ist kein Problem, ja also Telefonanlage
ist wirklich schwarze Magie, es gibt noch was anderes, Telefonanlagen sind komplett
schwarze Magie, und Tür-Gegensprechanlagen sind auch komplett schwarze Magie, but why,
kannst du machen, aber, also je nachdem, wenn es, also wahrscheinlich kriegst du es irgendwo
gebraucht, weil ansonsten stellt sich sowas keiner daheim hin, ist stimmt, Routen ist
circa 5% von dem, was die Fritzbox macht, die wollen, dass ich es DSL-Router nenne,
war ein Artidienstleister in Frankfurt, recht bekannte Lade in der Nähe vom Hauptbahnhof,
naja gut, da gibt es sehr viele, also in Frankfurt gerade Nähe zum Hauptbahnhof ist, wo du hinspuckst,
irgendeine Bank und irgendein Rechenzentrum, also in Frankfurt kannst du eigentlich sagen,
Finanzdienstleister am Hauptbahnhof kann alles sein, oder IT-Dienstleister am Hauptbahnhof
kann auch alles sein, waren leider nur Personalabteilungen, ja, also ganz im Ernst, wenn die Personalabteilungen
Einstellungstest mit dem DSL-Moder macht, das ist, wolltest du zur Tele kommen direkt
oder was, sind die nicht auch immer im Hauptbahnhof, also ganz im Ernst, wenn der Personala den
Einstellungstest mit dem DSL-Router macht, das ist ja schonmal, da läuft ja schonmal
grundsätzlich etwas falsch, oder, ich stell mir das gerade vor, sitzt hier ein Personalmensch
und guckt auf seinen Stichwort-Zettel, was ist das für ein Gerät, ok, der Kandidat
muss DSL-Router sagen, wenn er irgendwas anderes sagt, dann ist er durchgefallen, ja, WLAN-Router
ergibt tatsächlich wenig Sinn, ich mein klar, wir wissen das damit, ein Kombigerät
gemein ist aus Router und WLAN-Access-Point, aber WLAN-Router ergibt wirklich nicht allzu
viel Sinn, ja, ne, ein Layer-3-Switch kann bei Weitem nicht das, was eine Fritzbox kann,
kann ein Layer-3-Switch, VoIP, SIP, Deckt, NAS-Funktionalität, TV-Tuner, Kindersicherung,
WLAN, Gäste-WLAN, DSL-Modem, mir fällt den grad nicht mehr ein, ne, das kann ein Layer-3-Switch
nicht, Firewall, na wobei, da könnt ihr mir vorstellen, dass das manche Switche tatsächlich
sind, ein Layer-3-Switch ist ja auch kein Switch, sondern, naja, ein Router, beziehungsweise
ein Router mit einem ziemlich guten Switch drinnen, die Bezeichnung Layer-3-Switch triggert
mich ja auch immer ein bisschen, wobei mir letztens, glaube ich, es können sogar Topics
gewesen sein, im Stream dann doch relativ plausibel erklärt hat, dass es tatsächlich
Layer-3-Switche gibt, also, ich bin ja der Meinung, rein das Switchen an sich ergibt
auf Layer-3 ja keinen Sinn, weil Switching ist was, was, also, eine ureigene Sache von
Layer-2 und mir fällt nichts ein, was Layer-3 mit Switchen zu tun hatte, mit Switchen zu
tun hätte, wenn man jetzt sagt, ein Switch, der managable ist über ein Webinterface und
dementsprechend eine IP braucht und alles, da könnte man sogar sagen, das ist ein Layer-7-Switch,
weil er hat ja ein Webinterface, also daran kann es schon mal nicht liegen, also könnte
man noch eigentlich so weit gehen und sagen, ein Layer-3-Switch ist im Endeffekt ein Router,
der allerdings hardwaretechnisch hauptsächlich für Switchen ausgelegt ist, also quasi in
Hardware-Switching-Module, aber Routing vielleicht über die CPU und jetzt nicht so die ultra
krasse Bandbreite und nicht vielleicht die Hardware, die darauf ausgelegt ist, genau,
es ist ein Router, der hauptsächlich für Switch-Workloads ausgelegt ist, das könnte
man doch so sagen, oder?
Ist ein Layer-3-Switch dann ein Multifunktionsgerät?
Also wenn man es ganz streng sehen will, ja, aber ein Multifunktionsgerät ist ja im Prinzip
dann schon fast alles, wenn es darum geht, dass es mehr als eine Sache kann, ich meine,
ein Switch kann auch mehr als eine Sache, ein Switch kann auch mehr als Switchen, Switch
kann zum Beispiel so etwas wie Spanning-Tree machen, Ports hoch und runter fahren, zum Wlan
der Fritzbox hätte man einen Flaschenhals, das ist korrekt, das ist richtig, aber die
100M mit Fritzbox haben eh kein krasses Wlan, also weniger, was benutzt die Fritzbox eigentlich
für ein Routing-Protokoll, gar keins, Static-Routes kannst du da einfügen, sonst nix, und ansonsten
macht die Fritzbox halt das, was so jeder 0815 Router auch macht, es erkennt, welche
Ports ab sind und was da für IPs anliegen und trägt das halt automatisch in seine Tabelle
ein, beziehungsweise das Modem bei der Einwahl als Default Gateway, aber ansonsten kannst
du bei der Fritzbox nur einzig und allein statische Routen machen, sonst nix, PoE macht
auch, machen auch viele, ja, ein Router, ja bei den Cisco Leuten ist das immer ein Router,
Router, Router, ok warte, wie sagen die coolen Leute das, Routu, was, Router, nein, nein,
die Amis, ah britische Aussprache, hier guck mal, Router, Router, Router, bei mir ist das
auch ein Router, so, ja, das wundert mich tatsächlich in dem Fall auch nicht, das ist
ja bei viel, also bei meinem billig Mikrotik-Router ist das auch so, wobei du da immerhin sagen
kannst, welche Ports auf die Hardware beschleunigte, ich nenne es mal Hardware beschleunigte,
Pritching Chips gemerkt sind intern, also bei meinem Mikrotik-Router kann ich beispielsweise
sagen, ah ok, Port 5 soll aber an der extra Pritch hängen und die ist dann aber nicht
mehr Hardware geswitcht, wie auch immer man das nennt.
Ja Cloud ist doch ok, Cloud ist halt äußerst nichts sagend, kann ja alles sein, aber weil
aus Cloud sind wir doch eigentlich schon raus oder, also wenn du heute nicht Serverless
mit Blockchain und AI bist, bist du eigentlich schon outdated.
Gibt es eigentlich noch effektiv Kabelmodems, die man bei PCI Express, boah, ich habe keine
Ahnung, ob es, gibt es, gibt es PCI Express Kabelmodems, nö, gibt es nicht, habe ich
auch noch nie gesehen ehrlich gesagt so was, aber Mikrotik hat keine PCI Express Kabelmodems
oder wirklich, hab ich nicht gesehen, das will man aber eigentlich auch nicht, weißt
du warum man das nicht will, weil dann die externe IP direkt an deinem Rechner hängt,
das ist glaub ich nix was man haben will, das hatte man zu Modem und ISD Endzeiten schon,
das war damals schon kacke, aber ok, vielleicht gibt es einen Anwendungszweck, ich weiß es
nicht, aber ist mir nix bekannt.
Du bist froh nicht bei denen gelandet zu sein, was ich da in der Ausbildung von Midazubis
gehört habe, gehalten, aber Ausbildung soll wohl auch nicht so nice sein.
Tja, hast du aber Glück gehabt, ich hoffe du bist jetzt wo besseres runtergekommen, äh,
das ist ein Terminal, was gibt es hier, tatsächlich, MonkaS, Leute Sekunde, Sekunde, wurde gerade
eftig geflashbanked, PCI Network Interface, Moment, das ist, das ist ein Routerboard auf
einer PCI Express Karte oder was, das ist ja mal Pfeifer da, ok, das ist aber was anderes,
das ist kein Kabelmodem, das ist ein vollständiges Routerboard mit eigenem Betriebssystem drauf,
nur das ist, wozu nimmt man denn das, also da habe ich keine, keine Idee für Anwendungszwecke,
absolut keinerlei Plan, also da würde ich eher gucken, dass ich eine Netzwerkkarte nehmen
und direkt ans Modem dran gehe und ja, mich dann damit irgendwie einwähle, ich, ich hab
mir da noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, keine Ahnung, sind ihr JavaScript Profis, ja,
jede Menge und, und Cobol, kennen wir uns am besten mit aus, also wir machen unser Backend
immer mit Cobol und das Frontend mit JavaScript, also du kannst natürlich trotzdem fragen,
wir haben viele Leute, die kennen sich wirklich mit JavaScript gut aus, ich selber kenne mich
auch ganz brauchbar mit JavaScript aus, aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich da heilfältigste
JavaScript Hacker-Man bin, den es gibt, hast du Lust beim Meta zu arbeiten und langlebige
WC-Trennwände zu bauen, ja, aber immer doch, also wenn es, wenn es um Close geht, bin ich
immer dabei, WC-Trennwände Design 13, fast eine Werbung, da bin ich dabei, da würde
ich auch, da würde, also da würde ich auch wirklich gut dazu beipassen, zu Meta, warum
heißt die eigentlich Meta, ist Meta nicht Facebook, da würde ich auch wirklich gut
dazu beipassen, weil ich hab nicht umsonst, da hat sich wenigstens einmal gelohnt mir
einen 3000 Euro-Klo daheim hinzusetzen, ich kenne mich mit Close nämlich gut aus, ja
habt ihr euch abgesprochen, ha ha, lustig, beide haben so Mikrotik auf,
tja, er hat ja auch schon erkannt, dass Unify daheim nicht, der weiß, als letzter Schluss
ist, da sind wir uns auch einig, ja, meta.de, meta.com gar nicht so viel Unterschied, oder,
hier gibt es WC-Trennwände und bei meta.com gibt es den Zug, der irgendwie dir erzählen
will, dass Metaverse kommt, nee, finde ich auch nicht, also seit ich gelesen habe, dass
die Private Dynamic Pre-Shared Keys unterstützen, hat das bei mir wirklich einen großen Bonus.
So, was war denn die JavaScript-Frage jetzt, wo ist die JavaScript-Frage, also hier, ich
will gerne warten, oh das ist, warten ist in JavaScript immer eine ganz schlechte Idee
und jetzt no-cup, also wirklich, wirklich, wirklich no-cup, warten ist in JavaScript
immer ganz schlecht, du musst das irgendwie per Callbacks oder Async Await oder sonst
was machen, ach nee, ich sollte die Frage mal weiterlesen, ich bin immer Massive-Pepega,
was zur Frage angeht, bis ich etwas geladen habe, mache ich über Await new promise resolve,
ok, das Problem ist nun, muss ich jede Funktion, also Callbacks wahrscheinlich, wo ich das
benutze auch an Async mit Await deklären, kann man das irgendwie so machen, dass man,
dass man nur eine Async-Funktion, einen Await hat, weil danach ist es ja praktisch schon
synchron, ich versuche es gerade zu verarbeiten, also du machst quasi einen Fetch und Awaitest
das Fetch, so und dann gibst du irgendein Ergebnis in der Funktion zurück vom Result
des Fetches und diese Funktion rufst du irgendwo auf und dann müsstest du die wieder Awaiten
und da gibst du wieder was zurück und die müsstest du wieder Awaiten, nö, da gibt
es glaube ich nichts anderes, aber was du machen kannst ist, nicht fünfmal Nested die
Funktion aufrufen, sondern du könntest beispielsweise das Ergebnis des Awaited in Fetches, könntest
du dir je nach, ich weiß ja nicht, was du für ein Frontend Framework verwendest, könntest
du dann in irgendeine Variable schreiben und dann könntest du Reactive darauf reagieren,
sobald sich der Wert dieser Variable ändert, also so macht man das normalerweise mit halbwegs
modernen Frontend Frameworks, sei es jetzt React oder Svelte oder Vue, also in Vue würde
ich das so machen, in Vue hätte ich einen Mounted, also in Vue.js hätte ich einen Mounted
Hook, der läuft sobald die Komponente geladen wird, dann mache ich das Fetch, schreibe das
Ergebnis von dem Fetch in eine Variable von dieser Komponente und dann hätte ich irgendein
Element, was darauf reagiert, also dann hätte ich irgendein HTML, UI Element, was darauf
reagiert, wenn der Wert sich ändert dieser Variable oder ich hätte einen Watcher oder
ich hätte eine Computed Property oder was auch immer, die erst dann laufen, wenn sich,
also die dann Reactive laufen, wenn die Variable sich ändert und dann musst du nicht 50 mal
den Kram returnen und evaden.
Konntest du mir halbwegs folgen, ich glaube das war ein bisschen Confuse.
Ja ich mache keine normale Website, sondern WebGL Zeugs, ohne Server nur, ah ok, ah verstehe,
ich wollte einfach ein Sleep haben wie in C, aber scheinbar, nein das geht, tatsächlich
ist das in JavaScript ein bisschen eklig, ich meine du kannst das faken, ja, du kannst
ein Sleep faken, du awaitest einfach ein Set Timeout von einer Sekunde, das kannst du machen,
aber also musst ein bisschen mit Promises rappen oder so, aber das ist, das ist abfuck,
das ist wirklich eklig, ja, ne JavaScript ist tatsächlich nicht dafür gemacht zu waiten,
das ist, das ist, das ist, ja du hast recht manchmal ist das ein bisschen nervig, übrigens
Leute ich habe eine feifett Idee, einfach ein WebAssembly Modul machen, wo du dann die
C Sleep Funktionen expost, beste Idee oder, das soll, Moment das gibt es bestimmt schon,
GitHub, ich meine das nicht ernst ja, aber ich denke das gibt es bestimmt schon.
War klar, dass es sowas gibt, das ist witzig, ich habe letztens genau so was gemacht wie
du, also ob das das gleiche ist, weiß ich nicht, aber ich kann jetzt, ich habe es mit
einem richtigen, also ich habe es mit einem Fake Sleep gemacht, guck mal, ich glaube ich
habe es mir sogar noch offen, guck mal, ich rendere mit FFmpeg, ich rendere mit, du darfst
dich jetzt nicht dran stören, dass es C++ ist, das geht über WebAssembly, aber ist
jetzt wurscht, ich rendere Videoframes, guck hier beispielsweise hier neben mir, siehst
es da, da läuft jetzt ein Video, das wird im Browser decoded und gerendert mit FFmpeg
und hier drinnen mache ich ein ganz normales Sleep, was unter der Haube aber ein JavaScript
Async Sleep ist, also unter der Haube ist das ein SetTimeoutAwaitPromise Ding und das
geht über WebAssembly, ansonsten einen Tipp hätte ich vielleicht noch, vielleicht bringt
er dir was, ich weiß ja nicht genau wie deine Web Anwendung aussieht, ReactiveJS, ich kenne
das nur aus.NET, ich weiß nicht wie gut das in JavaScript funktioniert und wie beliebt
das in JavaScript ist und sonst was, muss ich mal kurz auf GitHub gucken, ok, es ist
fucking beliebt, das wusste ich gar nicht, das ist beliebter als die ursprüngliche.NET
Sache, mit ReactiveJS könntest du vielleicht auch irgendwelche netten Dinger machen, wenn
du Event Streams hast oder sowas, ich habe aber keine Ahnung wie sehr das zu deiner Anwendung
passt oder auch nicht, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht React, nicht React, RxJS,
das ist was anderes, das ist nicht React, das ist nicht React, ich meine RxJS, das ist
was anderes, das ist nicht React von Facebook, RxJS, da kannst du solche Sachen zum Beispiel
machen, wenn du verschiedene Event Streams hast, ja, zum Beispiel irgendwas wirft immer
mal wieder Events, in dem Fall machen sie es hier mit der Range von 1-100, da kannst
du diese Events filtern und subscriben und weiterreichen und was auch immer, das ist
das gleiche wie die Reactive Extensions für.NET, aber da kannst du beispielsweise dich
subscriben zu deinen Events und dann darauf reagieren, wenn sie reinkommen, ich habe aber
keine Ahnung wie weit das zu deinem Anwendungsfall passt.
Ja, in der Situation überlege ich mir gerade was ich da machen würde, also fällt mir jetzt
nicht so viel ein, wie machen das denn die ganzen JavaScript 2D Frameworks zu Pixi, JS
oder so, wie machen die das denn mit weights, die müssen doch auch irgendwas eingebaut haben
dafür, weil gerade wenn du was rendest, manchmal musst du einfach warten, keine Ahnung, eins
durch Framerate, Sleep oder so, ja eigentlich haben wir was anderes gemacht, aber irgendwie
wurde ich ein wenig sidetracked, was ist das Java Spring Equivalent Express, wobei ganz
ehrlich Spring und Express hat nicht wirklich großartig was mit Spring zu tun, also ich
bin jetzt ja kein krasser Java Hacker-Man, aber soweit ich weiß ist Spring Boot mehr
oder weniger so ein Library Bundle für Web Anwendungen, also da kannst du dir dann auf
der Webseite beispielsweise anklicken, ich möchte eine Web Anwendung machen mit ABC und
dann kannst du dir komplett das Bundle runterladen, das ist das was ich bisher von Spring Boot
gesehen habe, also sowas in der Art und Weise weiß ich nicht ob es das für Node gibt, aber
für Node ist somit das verbreitetste wenn du Web APIs machen willst Express, also reine
simple Get Post sonst was APIs Express, das mit Abstand verbreitetste, so wo sind wir
eigentlich stehen geblieben, ich wollte eigentlich noch mehr einkaufen, achso ich wollte gucken
was ist denn die größte externe Platte die es aktuell gibt, halbwegs, dafak 74, äh
65 Giga achso, ja geil, ne sowas meine ich nicht, also gucken wir mal irgendwie ab 20
Bern, das sind auch schon wieder so Dinger, puh alter das ist teuer, ok wir machen das
mal raus wir gucken nach Preis Leistung, ach Datenträger Anzahl, ich mach das weg wer weiß
was die da, ob das gepflegt ist, Preis pro Terabyte, ähm falsch rum, also was ist denn
hier das günstigste, also das hier ist eine 14T, eine 14 Terabyte Platte für 219 Euro
extern, ich finde das klingt jetzt gar nicht mal so mies, was haben die, was hatten die
für einen USB Anschluss, ist das schon USB C, äh, ihh, das ist, oh ne, das ist dieser,
dieser ganz schlimme Dings, ich weiß nicht wie der heißt, dieser Müll USB Anschluss
den, den es nie hätte geben sollen, das ist, das schreckt, sowas kommt mir nicht ins Haus,
ich weiß gar nicht wie der heißt, USB Micro, USB 3 Micro B, aha alles klar, USB C, kann
ich hier USB C auswählen irgendwie, ich will, USB, USB C, ne, kann man hier nicht auswählen
was man haben will, USB, alt Mensch, Geizhals hier, USB, USB C, äh, das kann nicht alles
sein mit USB C, dann machen wir mal was anderes, dann kreuzen wir, dann kreuzen wir nicht USB
C an, sondern sagen wir wollen einfach uns mal die Dinger angucken mit USB 3.2 und USB,
ok das sind, das sind die, ja das ist SSD Kram, das brauchen wir nicht, was sind denn
das für Dinger, sieht aus, sieht fast wie aus Portal so ein Turm aus, viel zu teuer
man, was ist denn mit euch los, Alter, was ist das, ok danach muss ich nicht suchen,
ok ich mach, ich mach wirklich das simpelste nochmal, Preis pro Terabyte, dann guck ich
wo was brauchbares dabei ist, ne ich glaube du brauchst es tatsächlich kein 3,2, 3,1,
selbst 3,1 wahrscheinlich, wobei es ja gar nicht, Leute, was wir sagen ist schon wieder
falsch, das heißt ja gar nicht USB 3.1, die haben das retro, retroaktiv umbenannt, das
heißt ja jetzt USB 3.0, GAN, GAN, 1x1, genau, USB 3.2, GAN 1x1 heißt es jetzt ja, oder
GAN 2x1, ach du Scheiß, Alter, dass die sich dabei denken, 3.2 GAN 1x1 heißt es jetzt,
genau, jaja, Rudi, es heißt nicht mehr USB 3.0 und nicht mehr USB 3.1, weil das USB
Gremium der Meinung war, es ist eine gute Idee, Sachen, die schon rausgekommen sind
und einen Namen hatten, 5 Jahre später umzubenennen, dass der alte Name nicht mehr gilt, was jetzt
halt ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil auf den alten Geräten steht ja noch das drauf, das
USB Gremium dachte sich wahrscheinlich, hey, das kann nicht sein, dass es etwas älteres
gibt als USB 3.2 und dementsprechend haben sie das umbenannt, deswegen heißt es jetzt
ja auch USB, äh, gibt es USB 4 schon, ja das wird dann, genau, das neue USB 4 wird
dann GAN, GAN 3, 3x2 heißen oder so, ich blick bei den Bezeichnungen nicht mehr durch,
das ist einfach nur massiv weird, USB 4 ist Thunderbolt, ja, nur das Intel mittlerweile
was neueres rausgebracht hat, was noch besser ist, weil Intel festgestellt hat, das USB
Gremium ist ein Haufen unfähiger, ich will es jetzt nicht sagen, aber ein Haufen unfähiger
Leute, wir müssen das selber machen, weil die es nicht können, USB 4 ist USB GAN 3x2,
ja, ja, nee, nee, 3x2 ist es, oder, oh, abwackeln, haben diese ganzen, haben diese ganzen Festplatten
von denen, allen Ernstes, Mikro, Alter, Mikro, Mikro USB B, das ist doch ganz, ganz großer
Müll, ah ja, hier, hier ist die Erklärung, genau, ja, hier, hier, genau, also, USB 4
GAN 2x2, USB 4 GAN 3x2, alles klar oder, jetzt weißt du sofort Bescheid, USB 4 GAN 3x2, logisch,
oder, was, Tapes, ich will keine Tapes, na also mit Bändern will ich jetzt daheim eigentlich
nicht anfangen. Was sind deine Top 3 Programmiersprachen zum
Programmieren lernen? Hackey bist du noch da? Weil ich hab das schon oft beantwortet, wenn
du nicht mal da bist, dann muss ich das jetzt nicht nochmal, das fast nicht nochmal aufmachen.
Aber ich fang schon mal an, also, das beste für meinen Geschmack ist tatsächlich, du
bist noch da, das beste aktuell, wenn du nicht schon was ganz spezielles im Kopf hast, was
du machen willst, ist JavaScript. Einfach aus dem Grund, niemand kommt an Frontend Technologie
mehr vorbei. Ok, vielleicht der Mainframe Cobol Entwickler und wahrscheinlich auch nicht
mal der. Niemand kommt an Frontend Technologie vorbei. Dazu kommt JavaScript selbst ist mittlerweile
sehr vielfältig, du kannst Desktop Anwendungen damit machen, wir streiten uns jetzt mal nicht
über die Sinnhaftigkeit von Electron, aber du kannst Desktop Anwendungen damit machen,
du kannst Mobile Anwendungen damit machen, du kannst Webseiten damit machen und du kannst
Server Backends damit machen. Also JavaScript ist eines der flexibelsten
und umfangreichsten Sachen in der Richtung was es gibt und du brauchst zum Einstieg nur
einen Text Editor und einen Browser, sonst nix. Aus dem Gesichtspunkt alleine ist es schon
mal super. Lukas, danke für den Sub. Dazu kommt, für JavaScript gibt es tausende, zehntausende
Tutorials, Kurse, Reddits, alles. Also JavaScript ist wunderbar aus diesen Gründen zum Einstieg.
JavaScript die Sprache ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt mein absoluter Favorit, aber
im Vergleich zum C++ Gremium machen die eigentlich JavaScript über die letzten Jahre immer nur
besser. Es gab ein paar fragwürdige APs in der Zwischenzeit und es gab ein paar komische
Klassen, wo man sich gefragt hat, warum gibt es die überhaupt, aber insgesamt muss man
sagen JavaScript wurde die letzten Jahre immer besser. Im Gegensatz zu C++ wurde eigentlich
nur Vira. Ok also Nummer eins, wenn du noch keine speziellen Vorstellungen hast, JavaScript,
weil im Frontend Sachen und damit meine ich natürlich auch ein bisschen HTML und CSS
kommt man nicht drum herum und du kannst mit JavaScript alles machen was du machen willst.
Nahezu. Kannst vielleicht keinen Bootloader programmieren, aber zu 99% kannst du es mit
JavaScript machen. Vielleicht JavaScript dann nicht die allerbeste Sache für den Bereich,
du kannst es machen. Also JavaScript, wenn du JavaScript gelohnt hast, hast du dein Leben,
dein Entwickler Leben lang was davon. So als erstes JavaScript. Zweite und wie gesagt
es hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, was man letztendlich machen will, ist ja klar.
Beide ist, wobei den zweiten Platz teilen sich finde ich, je nachdem was man machen
willst, Go oder Python. Es sind zwar komplett unterschiedliche Sprachen, aber beide sehr
beliebt. Riesig viele Library, achso, auch ein Vorteil von JavaScript, es gibt so gut
wie alles an Libraries dafür, was du dir vorstellen kannst. Riesige aktive Community,
beide Sprachen, Tutorials, Youtube Sachen, Webcasts, super Unterstützung was Ideen angeht
und alles. Es kommt ein bisschen nur an was du machen willst. Wenn du dich vielleicht
für AI Sachen interessierst, dann würde ich sagen, vielleicht eher Python Sachen oder
falls du vielleicht sogar sagst, hey ich interessiere mich für irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen
Dinge, dann auf jeden Fall Python. Ansonsten, wenn es Richtung Cloud Software geht, ist Go
eindeutig die vorherrschende Sprache, also sehr viele der ganzen Cloud Tools, sei es
von Kubernetes angefangen, bis Terraform, bis alle möglichen Loadbalancer und Proxy
sind, das ist zum größten Teil alles in Go programmiert. Gibt es auch viele Python Sachen,
aber viele Cloud Sachen sind in Go programmiert und Go ist an sich auch eine gute Sprache
für den Einstieg. Ich persönlich mag die Go Syntax und die Go Philosophie nicht so
extrem gern, also ich finde Go an vielen Stellen zu minimalistisch und an manchen Stellen
zu doppelt gemoppelt, klingt jetzt komisch, aber beispielsweise, du kannst in Go auf drei
verschiedene Arten und Variablen anlegen, mit var, mit gleich, mit Doppelpunkt gleich
zum Initialisieren und gibt bestimmt noch ein paar Varianten, aber auf der anderen Seite
kannst du nicht einfach sagen, Array, Wear Element größer 1, sondern musst nur Vorschleife
machen und solche Dinge. Oder auch zu checken in Go, ist ein Key in einem Dictionary drin
oder ist ein Error aufgetreten nach und das ist alles ein bisschen Pain's Champ für mich,
ich will nicht sagen, dass es wirklich schlecht ist, aber ich finde das ist nicht so schön
gelöst in Go. Das wären so die auf Platz 2 und ich persönlich mag ja.NET und C-Sharp
am liebsten. Du kannst in C-Sharp vielleicht nicht so vielfältig alles machen wie mit
JavaScript, aber dafür wo du was machen kannst ist es ziemlich gut. Also du kannst beispielsweise
in C-Sharp nicht sonderlich gute Mobile Anwendungen entwickeln. Ich weiß, dass es Möglichkeiten
gibt und bestimmt kommt jetzt der ein oder andere um die Ecke und sagt, habe ich schon
gemacht, aber alles was ich von Xamarin gesehen habe, hat mich abgeschreckt, aber.NET ist
eines der besten, finde ich, Backend Sprachen, also für das Backend von Web Anwendungen.
Auf dem Windows Desktop gibt es natürlich auch nichts besseres. Für Kommando Zeilen
Tool, finde ich, ist auch eine super Geschichte und wenn man in Azure ist, ist es auch für
Cloud Sachen ziemlich gut. Und ich mag C-Sharp einfach und C-Sharp hat einen riesen Vorteil,
Microsoft erweitert die Sprache jährlich, die haben ein jährliches Release führen
von neuen.NET-Versionen und neuen C-Sharp-Versionen und die schaffen es tatsächlich zum größten
Teil sinnvolle neue Features zu bringen. Also das was das C++-Cremium seit 10 Jahren nicht
geschafft hat, macht Microsoft in einem Jahr. So. Und ansonsten, habe ich dazu oder haben
wir dazu auch ein Video gemacht, vor noch nicht all zu langer Zeit und zwar, das ist
schon wieder ein Jahr her, ernsthaft, krass. Was haben wir denn empfohlen, Go, Python,
Javascript, ok, das wollte der Florian unbedingt haben, ich halte nichts von C und C++ als
Einstiegssprache, aber wenn er meint, und ich natürlich mit C-Sharp.
Naja, kann doch schon sein, dass ich das mal brauche, also das schöne ist, wenn ich
Backups mache, ich kann mir die mounten und dann auch durchsuchen, wenn ich gucken wollte,
wo ist was drin und so. Das ist ne Tapes, mit Tapes will ich daheim nicht rumhantieren.
Lucas, danke für den Sub. Lohnt sich eigentlich ein Zertifikat in einer Programmiersprache
zu machen? Also wenn du mich fragst, dann nicht. Es gibt bestimmt Leute, die sehen
das anders, aber ich weiß nicht, was es bringen sollte. Also ist Javascript richtig gut, um
richtig in Hackermans rein zu kommen. Naja, für Web-Anwendung brauchst du natürlich
die Kombination des HTML, Javascript und CSS. Es kommt noch was, was du machen willst. Javascript
ist, finde ich, die beste Einsteiger-Programmiersprache aus den eben genannten Gründen. Das heißt
nicht, dass ich sage, Javascript ist die beste Programmiersprache, aber zum Einsteigen ist
das Javascript Ökosystem und Javascript als Programmiersprache finde ich das beste. Wie
würdest du... Ja, das würde ich auch eher im wissenschaftlichen Bereich einordnen.
Ja, CSS ist abpackt, das stimmt. Dictionary ohne Keys funktioniert doch gar nicht, oder
wie jetzt? Also der Sinn von Dictionaries ist ja, dass man Keys hat. Von der Schwierigkeit
her, Javascript ist nicht so schwierig. Javascript ist an vielen Stellen etwas wir. Das liegt
zum größten Teil daran, weil die Sprache eben rückwärts kompatibel ist und es sie
seit 25 Jahren oder so gibt. Aber das ist zum größten Teil logisch. Also Javascript
ist auch keine super komplizierte Sprache. Das geht schon. Das ist, wie gesagt, die Kombination
aus dem, was ich gesagt habe und dass es auch an sich von der Sprache nicht kompliziert
ist, macht es, finde ich, zur besten Einsteiger-Sprache. Das ist in Javascript nur klar. Ganz, ganz
viel. 90% von dem, was die Leute täglich verwenden, sind echte Programme in Javascript.
Java ist auch gut für den Einstieg. Auch wenn ich gerne ein bisschen Java flamen, ich kann
mir das tatsächlich vorstellen, dass Java ganz gut ist für den Einstieg. Also wenn
ich aus meiner Sicht C-Sharp und Dornett empfehle, man muss ja sagen, Java ist jetzt nicht so
extrem weit von C-Sharp weg. Ich finde es halt Paynes-Champ im Vergleich zu C-Sharp.
Wie viel Oracle daran dreht, kann ich nicht einschätzen. Ich bin im Java-Ökosystem nicht
drin. Also so schlecht wird es nicht sein. Aber ich hätte kein Bock drauf, als mit Java
anzufangen. Nein, zum Einsteigen eindeutig Javascript. Wenn man was mit Typen machen
will, kann man mit C-Sharp anfangen oder mit Go, aber nicht mit TypeScript. Das finde
ich dann zu Overkill, wenn man damit anfängt. Noch on, aber nicht mal lang.
Wenn es danach geht, müssten wir alle mit Rust anfangen. Dann bist du halbwegs safe
und hast noch nicht mal einen Garbage-Collector. Aber Rust ist halt wirklich für den Einstieg
nix. Rust brauchst du einfach, du brauchst den Ultra-Wasserkopf für Rust. Also Rust
in Head.
okay leute
netter schwetztream wieder mit euch
ich wollte heute nicht aufbleiben nachdem ich gestern schon gesagt habe ich komme
on und bin da nicht mehr on gekommen
ich hau jetzt ab ich muss pennen
morgen muss ich das wird witzig
morgen muss ich mit einem
rein
englischsprachigen aber auch nicht native speaker
englischsprachigen telekom techniker zeugs zusammen installieren
und
der redet wahrscheinlich genauso geiles englisch wie ich
allerdings
mit einem anderen dialect
und im zweifelsfall machen wir es wie der öttinger gesagt hat
in my homeland baden-württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat
oder so in der richtung
ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt
okay also ich bin weg leute wir sehen uns bis denn zu